arrested in his home in Bucharest last
night no criminal charges have been
filed now we're in February so it's been
10 months they still have not been
charged
there's no evidence in my files there's
nothing wrong neither me nor batteries
are victims in this case there are no
victims in this case and I am not a
victim
I think you were the last interview of
Tate before you went to jail he gets
women into this like mind state where
they're very much into him what's
happening is they had nine months to
investigate and they wired capture the
brothers they were looking at their
private Communications they had the
witness statements of the women they had
psychological reports um he basically
has like this cam girl Sweatshop set up
in their basement where he's got all
these women working uh defrauding them
on their taxes and stealing money from
them so were the girls free to leave the
whole time
what he said he did in his videos he is
a significant full stop well you can
never have a scenario where you
basically detain someone and take away
someone's Liberty and then investigate
and try and find the evidence I'm
putting myself in these girls shoes I
get a boyfriend right and the boyfriend
convinces me to do cam work that was my
decision that's great that you think
that that's personal decisions
you're not cut me off like I'm just
tired we're gonna blame the men for your
poor decision
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today we are
hosting a debate on Andrew Tate welcome
Destiny to the channel he is a political
commentator with over 500 000 YouTube
subscribers welcome back destiny hey
what's up I like the totally non-biased
introduction that I got lots of air time
there next to him thank you
uh but thanks for having me do you have
an issue with the trailer yeah I did I
have an issue with the trailer I think
you were in my sections more than I was
but that's okay to be to be fair I
actually I I did not edit that I don't
know that's okay listen it's your show
so you know thank you thank you um and
we have Solomon Ahmed and he is a he has
a background in law and he has been
studying the Andrew Tate case welcome to
the show thank you for having me
um so um to start
is Andrew Tate guilty or innocent
uh I personally think there's enough out
there that Andrew Tate himself has said
that unless he's lying about what he's
done he's obviously guilty of at least a
few things uh namely defrauding the
women that he gets to work for him
probably sex trafficking via the
Loverboy method um but I don't think
anybody should be convicted of a crime
unless adequate evidence is brought
forth in a fair court and then he's had
his day to defend himself so I think
he's probably guilty but I think we
should wait and see how the process
plays out okay and what is your take
yeah my tech is looking at the evidence
and looking at the data that we have in
front of us I don't believe he's guilty
and that's all we can base it on is that
evidence is supposed to snippets on
YouTube or
things that have been phrased up
portrayed in a certain way VIA social
media
so Destiny you mentioned the Loverboy
method do you think that the loverborn
method is actually sex trafficking and
why
um I don't have thoughts on it or it's
not like my goal is to Define like what
is sex driving I just go by what the
laws are and usually the questions are
is he guilty of the crime of sex
trafficking and the Loverboy method is
defined as sex driving I believe in most
countries because at least in Romania
and I think in most countries if you are
able to get a girl to do sex work using
a coercive or fraudulent method meaning
you're Miss uh you're misleading them as
to what your relationship is then that
would constitute sex trafficking if you
exploit them afterwards for sex work
okay what about you yeah I agree with
what Destiny said just towards the end
so basically Loverboy method is a method
by which human trafficking occurs so if
someone did human sorry if someone did
Lover by Method on its own that would
not be a crime so what makes it a crime
is when you do the Loverboy method and
then you meet the requirements of human
trafficking and therefore you then meet
the standard so on its own lower body
method a person would not be convicted
of human trafficking solely based on
Loverboy method so where do you guys
disagree then
I mean I think you're kind of on the
same page I mean I actually don't know
what Destiny's position is so I'd
actually like Yeah well my position is
we should wait and see what the court
system does I think everything they've
done up to this point has been A-Okay
seems to be by the books um and then I
should I think we should wait and see
how the process plays out I believe
there's uh in Romanian law up to a
maximum of 180 days so they can remain
detained while they finish their
investigation and then it's up to the
Romanian Court to decide whether or not
they want to bring charges to the Tates
right so in terms of what what uh
Destiny said I don't think that they've
done everything A-Okay that's the first
point and the second point is I do
believe that they've contravened certain
um domestic as well as International
laws and then separate to that when it
um and separate of that evens when you
look at the
um reminding someone for 180 days
although that doesn't contravene law I
have serious issues with that as well
could you wait could you see the second
part of that again yeah so so the 180
days although that is within Romanian
law I have serious issues with it and I
can expand on that few hours okay yeah
could you tell me why yeah of course so
basically we have a scenario where in
Romania you have you can basically
detain someone without having adequate
evidence to prosecute or convict so
essentially you detain someone take away
the liberty and rights put them in
prison and then say guess what I'm
looking for evidence now I understand a
lot of people may not understand the
problems with this but coming from the
background that I am being a Muslim
being an Asian most a lot of our
community have been through this both in
the United States and the United Kingdom
when your Liberty is taken away without
due process without having a trial
without evidence being submitted and so
for us from the perspective of
minorities and perspective from that
perspective we have serious issues
because that was used to terrorize our
community for more than 20 years so yes
I will speak out about that even if it's
in the United States the United Kingdom
Romania France I think it's a serious
issue when you could take away someone's
Liberty without having adequate evidence
and six months is horrendous to take
away someone's Liberty that's a
significant period of someone's life to
say we haven't got enough evidence we're
going to jail you for six months and
then we're gonna look for the evidence
do you agree with him or no
um I would if what he was saying was
true so okay
um I feel like there's a lot of tricky
word games being played when we talk
about detaining somebody without enough
evidence so in the Romanian legal system
if you are in the finishing stages of an
investigation you can detain somebody
while you finish that investigation up
especially if you believe the people
that you're detaining might be a Flight
Risk you can detain somebody without
having enough evidence to charge them
with a crime or convict them of a crime
obviously but you do require compelling
evidence to detain somebody which is
left to the discretion of the judges
that are willing on the case I've
noticed that you've quoted that document
sometimes the one that was released in
it was either November or December where
the judge said that there's not enough
evidence to convict of a crime you've
said that several times but they're not
looking for enough evidence to convict
them of a crime but the judge was
supposed to evaluate was is there enough
evidence to Warrant detaining them and
he did feel like there was enough
evidence at that time and the statements
that he's made and the Romanian criminal
code are all completely okay with the UN
and with the United States and with any
other International legal body so I
don't understand when we try to push
against the Romanian legal system why we
say things like it's against
international law or it's against
International freedoms when this is how
the Romanian criminal court system has
been structured it's one of the reasons
why Andrew Tate you know verbally said
he was going to move there I don't agree
that it's in violation of any
International laws if it is I'd like to
hear which ones
your first point about
um in terms of the level of evidence
that was required to remind him so my
position is that it's unacceptable to
remind someone when you haven't got
enough evidence to prosecute or to
convict the threshold to Wholesome one
isn't uh isn't the way you framed it
where it's very close to basically
prosecute or convict the evidence is
based on Reasonable Suspicion so the bar
is very low to meet that threshold hence
why I have a problem with it if the bar
was much higher it was close to Beyond
reasonable doubt maybe even if it was um
balance of probability we could maybe
talk about that and look at the
possibility of why that would be
acceptable but when the balance is
reasonable suspicion the bar is very low
it's easy to me and that's why I think
so unacceptable first point second point
in terms of where they've contravened
international law that's a separate
issue so I will go into that because I
know you've asked a fair question so
I'll just I'll just go through it so
first of all Article Five one of the
European European commission which is a
corporate intermedia law so it breaks
European law as well as
um
domestic Romanian law states that
whenever you provide evidence or
prosecution provides evidence he has to
provide evidence both for and against
his stance that's not happened he has
not included evidence which is for
example the CCTV evidence he has not
included for example evidence which is
um long-form text messages which include
the entirety of the conversation he's
not included the witness statements
three of the women's statements of the
alleged victims who say they're not
victims so those are examples of
contravent Article Five One the convened
article 9 2 which this one we can argue
because uh the first one I don't think
there'll be much argument but second one
nine two is you can only detain on
exceptional circumstances and then 9-4
is that basically it's illegal to detain
someone unless the circumstances are
exceptional and in this case the
exceptionality or the illegality or the
problematic issue was that basically the
psych report was used as a basis to
detain them and the psych report has
significant issues in it and I can go
into depth in that if you want would you
like me to actually move on well for the
I guess for the first point that you
bring up [__] we should get a notepad to
write down on a notepad yeah
unironically for the first part that you
bring up um so saying that you need
Beyond a probable
um Beyond probable doubt
um I'm sorry reasonable or Beyond
Reasonable Doubt no no no sorry yeah
Reasonable Suspicion okay Reasonable
Suspicion
um I think it's maybe fair to take issue
with these things but I mean different
courts across different countries are
allowed to set up their legal systems in
the ways that they see fit and the
Romanian courts are set up in a way that
is in accordance with the European
commission um the judge himself
references the EC and provides the
evidence that they have for the EC in
the statement that he released in order
to make sure that it was on the up and
up
um I I it's I understand that the desire
to critique the Romanian legal system I
wouldn't want to live in a system like
that personally but that's why I moved
to the United I live in the United
States I haven't moved to another
country to participate in that legal
system you have the Patriot Act in the
United States as well we have the
similar Provisions we might have sure we
might but I'm just saying that Andrew
Tate the Tates specifically moved to
Romania because they said they wanted to
specifically take advantage of that
legal system there are videos of Tate
saying lock me up in jail I'll give them
a thousand dollars and I'll be out and
I'll have a musus and blah blah blah and
he's saying that and he moved to that
system and that system is legal insofar
as the EU framework is concerned because
nobody's challenged it nobody has said
anything about it and I think that to
try to call out that particular way of
doing things now I think Rings a little
bit Hollow okay I'll answer that and
then we can move on to the Article Five
Point so in terms of the reason of
Suspicion yeah again I have a huge
problem with it irrespective of Andrew
te thought he was in a situation where
he there was lenience in the in leniency
in the law that was error on his part
but it doesn't mean that just because
someone makes a silly decision and
assumes that certain laws you know this
that is unaware of the the legalistic
system in a certain country that he
should then the harshness of it we
should ignore as well in terms of the
harshness of it the reason why we have
severe issues is because it's I can
understand why you may not understand it
but people from the minority Community
who have been abused and terrorized by
these laws they understand what the
problem is by it and so for all of it
for us we're not just hating on the
Romanian system we're saying anywhere in
the world that has detention without
having a significant amount of evidence
where you know you can prosecute or
convict is something that we will speak
out about and it's wrong so it's not
just the Romanian system I said Germania
us UK France whichever country whichever
country is detaining people with only
based on minimal level of evidence which
is reasonable suspicion is completely
inappropriate unacceptable and we will
speak out against the irrespective of
who's being detained and so we have that
in Cortana mobile and significant
amounts of people from the United from
the Muslim Community who are being
detained without due process based on
Reasonable Suspicion and have never been
to trial do you think that Guantanamo
Bay a military prison setup outside of
the United States in order to maintain
like foreign prisoners or terrorists
like people without uniforms do you
think that's comparable to what's
happening right now in the Romanian
criminal court system
um so you make a fair point because of
it's not comparable in the time in the
sense of the timeline because some of
them have spent 20 years yeah but it's
comparable in the sense of the aspect of
and so I'd give that as an extreme
example so that's an example but also
people get detained for like 14 days 28
days three months six months nine months
without without it all of that is
unacceptable so okay when you say
unacceptable you mean to you it's not
violating any international law you just
personally don't like it yeah yeah yeah
no no well when I say I personally don't
like it I think it's something that as a
someone who's a member of the community
of the world irrespective of what it is
and because you don't experience it you
probably don't realize but it's a major
issue for all of us and it has been for
20 years that's fine but we haven't been
talking about it for 20 years we've been
talking about it for the past three
months really with the undertaking well
we've been talking about it for 20 years
sure I'm sure some people have yeah if
if you want to have a personal issue
with how some people do detainments
without I guess uh meeting a certain
threshold of you know publicly available
evidence I think that's an interesting
conversation to have but I'm pretty sure
that this particular thing has to do
with the Andrew take case and these
particular opinions have to do with
opinions about the legal system not
whether or not it's actually violating
international law so yeah I I don't like
the framing of I don't think this is
fair therefore it violates statements or
guidelines by the European commission
violated right yeah that wasn't my point
so okay because because you're
completing my two points so my point was
about Reasonable Suspicion specifically
why I have a problem with very clear
that that did not break international
law actually said it I said it it didn't
my proof of why it breaks international
law outside in Article Five and I'm
going to cite another five six more
legislations what he breaks and that
hasn't got to do with Reasonable
Suspicion that's got to do with uh
evidence
okay
um so the first one was the first one
was Article Five one which says that
basically the prosecution has a duty to
provide so for example in the United
Kingdom in the United States what
happens is the prosecutor gains the
information he and and this is the same
in Romania what should be according to
Article Five one as well as a condition
national law what the prosecutor does is
he gets information he looks at it look
this is the strong point for my case but
actually these are the weak points
because this proves the defendant's case
I'm gonna clear all of that and give it
to the pro give it to the prosecutor so
this in this case says die cut and then
the prosecutor then makes a decision
based on both of the evidence and
decides wait a sec the evidence isn't
strong enough causal cases weak at this
point I'm not going to take this forward
to prosecute and so in the United
Kingdom the prosecutor is called the CPS
I'm saying this where he's contravened
international law article 5-1 is he did
not provide the evidence that it weakens
his own case to be able to prosecute so
that was my first point so you're saying
they didn't give them the weaker part of
the case too so and you mentioned CCTV
footage of what right so CCTV footage of
so CCTV footage the imperative it
basically shows what it'll give us a
very good window into understanding were
these women detained were they
controlled were they let out it won't
give us the full scope but it'll give us
a significant score both inside and
outside they have the CCTV they also had
CCTV in the house where the girls were
living none of that has been included so
they didn't they didn't include the CCTV
footage that was actually in the house
when the girls were living there that's
right and so and and the defense wants
to include it and that's gonna be I'm
gonna explain why that Violet other
articles within international law which
is then incorporated into Romania law I
don't think they have to I don't think
there's an obligation for the court to
include every single piece of evidence
it's international law no hold on sorry
to include every single piece of
evidence that we would want the defense
to include right at some point
um I'm pretty sure that their goal is to
just balance out whether or not a future
investigation is likely to lead to some
sort of criminal charge it's not to
present the entirety of the defense's
case at that point in time to see if
they can dismiss the charges it's just
to see if there's enough to detain them
there for the investigation to continue
meaning they're going to begin to or
they're already in the process of
subpoenaing electronic records and
devices and going through chat logs and
everything and the judge and so far as
the statements he's released has felt
like there are uh significant enough
claims and I think publicly I think we
can all see that that it warrants
detaining them especially given that
there are Flight Risk so that the
investigation can conclude and it might
be at the end of that investigation to
decide well there's nothing going on
here and then they release them but it I
mean I think right now what we've seen
publicly is we've all seen this plenty
enough evidence out there to say it's
probably something here that's worth
investigating that that's not correct
because the reason why they have this
process is because you can give someone
who's been accused of a crime due
process he's given an opportunity to
present the evidence and then the CPS
makes the decision the reason for that
is because everybody knows if you have a
scenario in any kind of system where the
prosecutor only provides positive
evidence to try and prosecute and he
doesn't provide the evidence that
weakens his case you will end up in
trial no matter what and then what will
happen is everybody knows even if your
innocent trial risk could go wrong and
you could go to jail hence why they have
these uh things in place to ensure that
doesn't happen and innocent and more
innocent people aren't incarcerated and
someone and I know you're from the
United States where there's a huge
amount of incarcerations and more than
anyone per capita around the world as
well as for example in the United States
you have much more black people Hispanic
people 300 more who have been
incarcerated so again this is an example
of another black man who's basically
being incarcerated in sorry left do you
do not agree I don't know I don't think
this has anything to do with black men
or whatever that's being incarcerated I
don't know why that's even
oh it does it does because basically
you're ignoring the fact that he's in
Eastern Europe it's a basically
significantly has a significant amount
of issues in terms of race issues it
also has a significant amount of issues
in terms of sex trafficking yeah well it
has well and we will talk about that but
in terms of the significant areas issues
significant amounts of islamophobia you
have a scenario where this country has
not allowed
um any kind of dark dark immigrants into
their country but now they've changed
that for Ukrainian immigrants and
allowed a significant amount in you've
got significant amount history of
islamophobia so of course when a man
when a black man who is a Muslim gets
incarcerated immediately after he's
converted Islam and I think the one is
the investigation been going on well
since April well well they claim that
investigation has been gone for April we
don't know exactly it's gonna be
interesting to see when the evidence
comes out what evidence comes out but
what we do know is
he was do it just is there a single
shred of evidence to point to anybody at
any point of this process being either
as racist or islamophobic I've just
explained to you examples of how Romania
Romania has demonstrated that and also
I'm going to demonstrate to you
throughout this process how for example
people are not understanding that a lot
of the comments he makes is based on his
Heritage is based on his background
where he comes from something which I
understand you may not understand based
on your upbringing and you know being a
white man you know let me ask that yeah
let me ask that one more time is there a
single shred of evidence that anybody
has participated in an islamophobia or
racism
yeah yeah no no I've just given you
example of Romania being having a
significant amount of of racism well I
think it'd be harsh to color racism but
it is a significant indicator if you're
not letting people who have of dark dark
color into your country but you're
letting people of white color into your
country I think that says a lot okay so
I'll ask a third time and if you don't
have an answer that's fine you have
nowhere no no no any islamophobia or
racist no no president I've just giving
you evidence I've just given you were
telling me that the country as a whole
maybe I've had problems with racism but
in this particular case I'm curious if
there's any like in the United States if
something happens and a cop was racist
we might look for like a statement that
the cop has made you wouldn't just say
that like wow a black guy got arrested
that's a racism right but you're saying
that no no no because he got arrested
it's racism and islamophobia so I'm
curious if there's any evidence of that
whatsoever no no what I'm saying is when
you look at the scenario there is the
significant issues when it comes to the
fact that he is uh he is a black man and
he is a just converted to Islam and even
incarcerate in a Eastern European
country to ignore that is ridiculous and
I'll explain why because human again
this is a scenario where if you ignore
the issues of race if you ignore the
issues of someone's Heritage which is
happening a lot in this case because I
know and we're going to talk about some
of the videos that you're complaining
about then you can basically break it
into the Bare Bones and look at
literalism and convict anyone of
anything but it's illogical you have to
look at the background you have to look
at the history of the person and in
reality when when you take all them
things into consideration they have a
significant impact look this is quite
simple and because you can give these
examples and obviously you have to
generalize them this is a scenario where
let's be clear it's a person who's a
black man who's being again accused of
doing accused of rape or human
trafficking on essentially white women
um and being incarcerated in the Eastern
European country without enough evidence
I mean that takes me back according to
say that takes me back to you know for
example the United States and you know
in you know when these type of things
are happening in the plantation okay
basically you have a significant issue
where black people are being accused of
rape by white people and it's happened
significantly throughout the West you've
seen it now with Benjamin Mendy you
sorry
um Greenwood footballers who were
accused and now after losing so many
years of their life they've finally been
let out so they think that this is not
happening subconsciously or consciously
is is an issue okay so just this is a
personal feeling that I have I think
that when we pivot to other cases I feel
like it's because we know that this case
is very weak if you want to talk about
racism that exists the United States or
racism that exists in particular cases
um I'm free to do that at any point in
time but right now we're talking
specifically about the Undertake case
Andrew Tate is a man that has released
an entire University guide on how to be
a pimp on how to seduce women and get
them to work for you and how to sex
traffic on how to scam them on taxes on
how to do all of these things he's had
charges in multiple countries relating
to rape he's had charges in Romania now
relating to his entire business relating
to sex trafficking um to try to hand
wave all of this and go islamophobia and
racism would be okay if we had even one
iota of evidence a statement that a
prosecutor made a statement that a judge
has made uh any any type of evidence but
right now we don't have okay any of that
so I can only go by what I've seen in
front of so then based on that based on
that then you deny institutionalism
because you can never have a scenario
where you can have use specific evidence
for generalization but the whole point
is we use generalization to we should we
show many examples to then say look this
is a general issue
that's fine but we use generalization to
talk about General issues we don't use
generalization talk about it no no you
not at all what happens is you you use
specific issues to create a
generalization and then said
generalization is used for subsequent
issues that's actually how it works in
terms of
um coming back to the point because you
made up quite a lot of points in terms
of the allegations again because this is
another problem what we have and because
we're on the racial let's talk about it
so you have a scenario where you've
basically got a guy who comes from Luton
England who's basically got a background
in
look he was basically if you give a
American comparable he's basically from
the ghetto he has a scenario where
people from that that kind of upbringing
are talking in very much slang humor
ghetto type talk I'm a Gangster Emoji I
did this I did that that girl that this
that all that kind of stuff so that's
how they talk then to say oh guess what
he's talked like that therefore he must
have done these things he's calling
women like this he's he's saying that
he's done this he's done he said he's
done fraud all of these things are huge
hugely problematic in the sense of
you're basically
removing his history and Heritage now I
understand as a white man you may not
understand the background of Heritage
and these type of things that he's going
through but the issue is that's quite
important
do not do not agree no
um why not because me being white or
black or whatever has nothing to do with
him giving a deta I don't now I'm gonna
be honest okay I've only been in London
a few times okay now I haven't walked to
some of the roughest Parts but I haven't
maybe there are parts we walk around and
they're talking about how the top G's do
tax fraud on their employees maybe
that's just a way of speaking but if it
is a way of speaking and you detail it
it like into an incredible level and you
have a business where you claim to do
that and you put that out on videos on
social media and then you go to jail for
it yeah you're probably gonna get in
trouble um
let me finish responding okay your
entire point that this is just a way of
talking is ridiculous it is absurd he is
listed exactly a step-by-step guide on
how he lover boys girls into his sex
trafficking business he uses actual
prostitution terms like bottom [__] to
describe his relationship to some of the
employees that he has he talks about
bringing women into his into his company
to work them as sex traffic models and
then he specifically talks about
defrauding them using taxes to steal
money from them I don't think that I
think it's a little bit racist of you to
say that that's just how people from
ludin England or whatever talk or that's
how they function I don't believe that
is the case okay so I'll answer your
question so no again but your point is
actually doesn't make sense and it
doesn't follow it's not secretary and
I'll explain why the reason is because
when you look at what he said online
again do you give the example of bottom
[__] and so and so forth that's how
that that's basically slang that's how
people talk and that's what you're not
understanding in terms of let's look at
your example which is completely
ridiculous because what you're saying is
guess what he said this online therefore
he should be convicted based on it
online well that's the influence you're
making basically online you gave this
example you said he's trying to defraud
them because online what he actually
said was this in that video because I
know what the video you're referring to
he says in the same video he says oh I'm
gonna take all the money in the same
video he says I'm gonna give 50 50. in
the same video he says I'm gonna get 50
30 70 30 because you know 20 you know
should I'm going to tell us for um tax
purposes but then I'm gonna pay the
taxes and hence why you're making the
claim for fraud the point is this from
the court documents which I'm sure
you've read he it's none of that is in
there in the court documents what it
actually says is complete the opposite
what it says is and this is the worst
one so this is the worst woman she says
I received 50 he receives 25 so she
receives double of what she received
what he receives so that is nothing got
to do with uh has no links to the video
so what you're what and and she doesn't
mention anything about being defrauded
of taxes because she's receiving the
full she's receiving 50 percent
so what you're claiming is guess what I
don't care about what he's what the
court documents say I don't care what
the witness is saying but guess what in
the video he said this and therefore he
should be convicted or based on the
video no there's only two explanations
for the video because the court
documents don't add up to what the video
says either he was exaggerating and
talking in this kind of slang language
is what I'm trying to explain so he was
exaggerating and or it could be which is
a possibility that it was so long ago
that he did engage in those practices
and no longer does but what we know is
in this case what he is being charged
for so what sorry what he's being held
for he hasn't been charged yet so what
he's been arrested for no one says that
okay I so I'm sure you've talked to a
lot of people that have only watched
clips of Andrew Tate which is fair and I
think that a lot of people say a lot of
dumb things about him because they've
only seen Clips which is also not fair I
think people shouldn't do that
um but I think you're relying on me
having only seen Clips So you you're
trying to pass this off as slang when he
used that phrase bottom [__] he wasn't
passing it off his slang he was very
specifically detailing bringing girls
that were in love with him over to
dinner where he would introduce them to
his youngest youngest working or one of
his younger working models a woman that
he met at 16 that had been working with
him for five years is now 21 and how he
would use her to mislead the
relationship that they had so that she
could get the girl the new one that was
brought in into working as a as a cam
girl this is prostitute Behavior this is
pimping Behavior this is exactly what it
is when he says bottom [__] here he's
not just using slang in a funny way to
talk about a girl that's a friend of his
that also works with her girlfriend he's
literally detailing step by step the
process by how he would deceive and
mislead which are key components of sex
trafficking a new woman that he's
brought in with another woman he would
mislead the extent of their relationship
and then he would use that to get her to
go and be a cam girl so that that is not
slang right right let me finish that's
right you just talk for ages
yeah you just I just spent like half the
time
I go non-stop okay so it's not a slang
thing secondly you're bringing up this
thing that the witness says they got 50
that is not what the witness said the
witness said that originally there might
have been an agreement where it was a
50-25-25 split but the witness also said
that they were randomly dinged for
different charges that made it so they
didn't get that payout for instance if
you didn't stream the full 12 hours you
might be fined like one thousand to four
thousand uh whatever the Roman um
or whatever the Romanian currency is and
that there were a lot of things where
because one of the claims was they had
to work 12-hour shifts with a five
minute break and if they didn't work
enough there the witness also said that
if they didn't post enough on only fans
they didn't post much that they also
were doing their pay as well so while on
paper it might have been a 50 50 split
we have the issues where the witness is
saying that they've lost some of it due
to being fined and we also have the fact
that Andrew Tate on video has talked
about how to defraud the women with
their taxes and we have another
statement of him saying that he also
oftentimes just builds in cryptocurrency
which is impossible to track the women
would have no idea if she's getting that
or not
right so again your your Arc your this
statement that you relate is inaccurate
so the woman who said that 50 25 she did
she did no way we could pull this up on
screen the document that you guys are
talking about do you know what it's
called it's on some website spice
something is in Romanian
yeah you didn't bring a Romanian
translator are you even trying I thought
it was a serious show Dad
Jesus uh so how did you read it then the
document you got it someone translated
it and then oh okay but I don't know
about that Romanian you learned Romania
I have Romanian friends you can also use
a Google translate on this other thing
too yeah
I'll pull it down okay because we could
also pull up the video you guys were
talking about too so so in terms of what
you're saying that's not right because
the woman who claimed 50 never claimed
that she ever got fined I can set off
without doubt what she's claiming is
other women will find and their
percentage was much higher so that's not
right
she wouldn't know she would never no no
so she said this is the problem she's
sin I never got fined I got 50 because
you're trying to make it look like this
and this is what you're trying to
portray you're trying to portray this
point she got 50 then she got fined so
therefore the percentage reduced that's
basically what you're trying to explain
but what she said was no I got 50 she
never got fined other women who
allegedly got a bigger percentage were
fined that's what it was that's not true
but I was curious how would she know she
got 50
sorry how would she know she got 50
percent well she said she got 50 I'm
asking you how she would know how would
she know if she didn't
uh I'm going by Andrew Tate's statements
to figure out what was paid or not and
Andrew Tate himself has said that he
would try to scam the models but I'm
curious because no no no no no no no no
this is the problem you see because you
know again uh and another point is this
you know when you said you used the
bottom Bish method and you know he used
a woman to Lara and get another woman
there's no woman who's who's open till
now out of the victims whose information
we have no woman has claimed that that
occurred so no woman has said that
Andrew took her for dinner brought her
bottom [__] and then tried to Allure
her and convince her and then make her
go abroad no one has said that they all
have said that they all went abroad
based on their own interaction with the
tits and there was no other woman
involved in trying to Allure them how
many um do you know how many people
right now are um filed as injured
persons I think for the case yes eight
right seven are you sure I thought it
was six and then they added two more it
was six divided one more okay so it's
either seven or eight how many women
worked with him
what do you mean didn't he say at one
point that he had up to 75 women working
at one time that's what the website says
but again this is the problem so he did
say that and one can assume uh because
you're right he did say that I'm not
going to deny that he said like that
basically I had 75 women working for me
and that we could get rich together he
did say that okay in terms of what the
call information says it doesn't say
anything related to that in terms of the
BC documentary they try and portray the
fact that it's actually a very small
operation and there was hardly any women
has the prosecution leaked every piece
of evidence that they have
sorry has the prosecution leaked all of
the evidence that they had no no they
haven't so what they've leaked and no
they haven't so what they've leaked is
this and so what we know about and then
I'll explain to you what they've leaked
so what they what what we have is the
witness statement of the women right we
have the psych report do you think the
psychopath's acceptable uh I do yeah you
do why do you think it's acceptable
um it was done by professional what else
can I go by so you think it's acceptable
that a psych report was done on the U.S
moldovan woman and then based on that
psych report the psychologist made a
judgment that all the other women are
brainwashed so Jasmine and Beatrice she
never saw them she never met them she
never did a psychiatric report on them
and just based on them girls words she
decided that she they were brainwashed
do you think that's how that's how that
do you think I don't know the extent to
which you can guess the other one why
have we moved on to the soccer park why
do we jump no because you asked for the
evidence that was the second evidence
what no I was asking you seem to be very
confidently stating that the presence of
the bottom [__] that that hasn't been
mentioned by any other woman that's
right another person that's right but
how do we know the prosecution isn't
planning on bringing that up at trial
well we could look we we only we only
base on things on what information we
have right now the information we have
right now is we know there's a witness
statement we know there's a psych report
we have the two uh um rulings that were
leaked and we also have
um what else we have some of the some of
the whatsapps that were leaked
up I can't use you're telling me I can't
use any statement that Andrew Tate has
made in any of his videos or websites
that's not fair again for videos look
you you have to except look there could
be a architect I can take look I was
even going to do a low blow and I was
gonna I actually took a snippet from
your video where you said uh me and Lena
are racist but
guess what that was out of context that
was a joke you were making because you
were being humorous and it was there was
context because you were having a joke
with like somebody who's accusing you
sure what the point I'm trying to make
is that would be unacceptable for me to
use to then say you're racist so in
reality what will happen is this is what
I think this sorry this is in the
scenario where I think it should be used
or when it shouldn't be used so the
scenario where a video evidence should
be used let's say for example someone
says I killed Michael and then you see
Michael dead you'd be like okay he said
I've killed Michael online and Michael's
dead but if he says I've killed Michael
but then like Tony is dead that doesn't
mean that just because he said he's
gonna murder someone that he's murdered
Tony so the issue is this whenever
you're going to use something online the
specific usage has to be used so when
you're giving the example of the bottom
[__]
you now there needs to be evidence that
that actually happened and there's no
evidence that that happened based on
everything presented with yeah that
we've been presented with so but we've
been present with significance so I've
done a significant amount of research on
the moldovan woman there's nothing about
a bottom [__] this I've done a second
amount of research on the U.S woman
there's nothing about a bottom [__]
um Jasmine and Beatrice the same thing
this you UK um this new woman number
seven the BBC did she literally says she
actually explains how she went abroad
and it was based on her own decision her
introduction with Andrew test so we've
got five women so yeah there is a small
possibility that the other two women
could say that happened but right now
based on these five women no okay so
when you compare the joke about me
making a small racist comment saying no
no you're saying this let's say even if
I did yeah right the way that you would
evaluate the truthfulness of it he said
well let's look at his entire body of
really work I accept actually we do
exactly so if somebody's making comments
about Andrew Tate then we would look at
his entire body of work and so if we
look at what Andrew Tate's business is
or at least what he's claimed it is is
he's working with over 70 women and he
claims most of them are his girlfriends
are loyal to him a lot of them are
Eastern European he has talked about
defrauding them on their taxes he's
talked about using a body a bottom [__]
to rope some of them into his business
he's talked about how his brother has
talked about how he doesn't let any of
them read any of their Instagram
messages he's talked about how he
doesn't let any of them leave there's
been statements leaked by some of the
victims saying that they weren't allowed
to leave the premises without a
bodyguard or without one of the two
women going along with them that when we
look at all of this I don't think it's
fair to say that we're just taking a
single clip where we're just taking one
comment and we're trying to make the
claim like oh Andrew Tate is this
horrible person his entire model of of
caming from his brother talking about
how they would just scam men how oh here
you go oh that's kind of I gave you two
yeah
okay there you go okay we're
accommodating here yeah accommodating
Andrew Tate and Tristan Tate's entire
lives have been them openly talking
about how they are scammers and about
how they basically acquire women to use
for their business in ways that to any
sane person is going to sound like sex
trafficking well you're getting women
that are loyal and faithful to you that
you're going to get to do camming and in
multiple statements they've said like oh
and you know what they're my property
and I get all the money and then in
other statements uh Andrew is detailed
how he defrauds them on their taxes I
don't see how any insane person does
look at this guy like oh you know this
kind of looks like sex trafficking it
really does fit the bill completely so
okay so the basically two points the
fallacy of your position is this and
I'll get to the fallacy in a second
first things first
I agree with you you should take a
person's full body of information and
when you take Andrew Test full body you
have you've seen it online there's so
many of his fans have produced videos
demonstrating the complete opposite no
you shouldn't for all the women no you
should look after them you should take
care of them you should respect them so
on and so forth so you do have content
that is equally on the same level as the
content that you use to attack here and
that's my point when you use the whole
body there is a huge level of body of
information out there that shows both
the positivity of what he's doing and
the negativity of these statements
that's the first point in terms of the
second Point again you this is the
problem you're doing because I know you
have to do it because you know the case
doesn't line up with your point what
you're basically doing is separating
online content of what he's saying and
saying I don't care about what's
happening in the case that he should be
convicted based on that but guess what
I'm saying what he's saying online has
no correlation with what he's done so
therefore you can't use that as evidence
to then say he should be convicted what
you should be doing
and what you can do and I would find
that acceptable is if you did if he's
actually got a specific statement so
let's say the U.S woman says look he did
extra me specifically X naught the whole
thing and trying to make it look like
human trafficking and then you went and
found he did X in the video then you
could be like he did it but that's not
what's happening you're basically saying
he did this on the video I do not care
what the evidence did I'm gonna just say
that he's guilty so what you're
basically saying is guess what I'm gonna
trial him or I'm gonna convict him based
solely on social media content
irrespective of what the real life
content is and that's a problematic
because like I said you're not
understanding the point of and I try to
explain to you from a thinking point
when you thought it was a relationship
but you're not understanding the issue
of this people talk
in in humor people don't always talk in
Little literalism People exaggerate
people uh try and make their business
look a lot better than they did there's
a number of reasons for that but that's
basically what happens so in reality
when you're saying this we need to look
at it from a contextual point of view so
that's the first point so now you what
you need to do is give me if you want
something as evidence give me something
in the documents something that they've
done that you say yeah they should be
convicted because guess what right now
the judge doesn't agree with you because
the judge said there's a reasonable
suspicion but there's not enough
evidence to prosecute and convict so
that's why the prosecutor for the last
nine months as well as these two months
is looking for the evidence because if
you add that if he had the evidence to
convict them or prosecute them even
before that he would have used it but he
knows that this social media content
that you're talking about that doesn't
match up with what the real life
evidence and claims of the women are so
what what you are saying is guess what
I don't care what the judge says it
doesn't matter that the judge says that
there's not enough evidence to prosecute
and convict
that's not good enough for me I'm going
to look at social media content and he's
and he's guilty okay so I'll reiterate
what I said at the beginning of the show
um only one of us here seems interested
in having the process follow itself
completely and that's me I said that
whatever they find I think that if they
find enough to bring charges then they
should have a trial and if they do well
on their trial the prosecution then he
should get convicted that's how it
should work it might be the case that
after the prosecution digs further that
they don't fight enough and Andrew Tate
and Tristan and the other two women end
up walking that could be the case and if
that is the case then that's fine I'm
not here saying that he should be
convicted you keep saying that he should
be convicted I think that I don't
believe that he should be convicted
based on what he said in his social
media post thanks
um okay cool but yeah I think that's but
I think that it's I think that it's okay
so what do we disagree hold on hold on
well I'll tell you yeah the first thing
you said is look at his full body of
work okay his full body of work is that
he treats women like property when he
has some Tick Tock videos that say
things like you should look after women
and respect them and take care of them
he's taking care of them as a pimp takes
care of his prostitutes and he's
reiterated that multiple times that the
women belong to him that they're not
allowed to go out without him they can't
go to the club without him they can't do
these things without him that they stay
home all the time and they they cook and
they clean and they hold on let me
respond to his things please and then
you can say whatever okay okay yeah that
he's multiple times stated this and his
brother Tristan has stated the same
thing as well that they're not allowed
to look at their Instagram DMS that he
controls all of their social media
accounts he may probably control their
income as well I would imagine that
would extend to that so when you say
that there's a counterbalance while on
one end he's treating women like
property but on the other end he's
saying that respect them because you
need to own them as as sex workers
essentially or own them as house slaves
I don't think that that's a good
counterbalance you bring up this point
again and again he should be convicted
based on social media things I have not
said that he should be convicted what
I'm saying is that and what you agreed
to is that the prosecution hasn't given
us every single piece of evidence if
Andrew Tata said I defraud people on
their taxes I don't think that he should
be convicted for it I think that would
be a good point for the prosecution to
say okay well let's start subpoenaing
records and let's see what have these
girls actually been paid they should
have bank accounts there should be
income statements from his caming
websites and then the prosecution can
look and they could go this woman earned
you know 50 000 Romanian dollars and she
was paid you know 25 000 remaining
dollars well everything here is probably
good and they move on but maybe she
earned fifty thousand dollars and for
some reason she's only getting paid 500
Romanian dollars then that would be
probably something you would bring in
court and say hey look this is part of
the charges we're running against you
you are clearly defrauding these women I
don't know what the extent of that
investigation is going to be because
right now I don't have any insight into
what the prosecution has besides what
they've leaked to the public or
presented to the judge to maintain that
the Tates remain in prison until they
finish their investigation
um the people talk [__] humor and all
of this again I'm going by full length
videos that I've watched of Andrew and
Tristan Tate explaining how they work
with women and explaining their business
I'm not going by little equips I'm not
going by small Clips I'm not going by
jokes I'm just listening to how they
describe the process of what they do and
if you listen to it it sounds
indistinguishable from pimping
would you would you agree that the CCTV
footage should be included I mean I
don't know what the particular I don't
think it's ever weird like why wouldn't
they have that in there what I don't
know what I don't know what I don't know
what evidence they need to have on both
sides because they don't need every
single piece of evidence well I'm just
thinking like if you're gonna go off of
because you know you guys know a lot
more about this than I do but basically
like they
that Andrew and Tristan were like
running this operation wouldn't CCTV put
footage be the perfect thing to see you
know like the promise I don't know if
the CCTV footage is just positive right
it might be the case that there are
videos of them partying inside but it
might be the case that believing the
compound is actually incredibly
difficult that you're not once you step
outside you get in trouble also um
according to Romanian criminal law
statements from victims um can't get rid
of sex trafficking like a victim can't
consent to that so even if a victim says
oh well you know this was all fine and
it was okay if text message logs are
released where he's saying like oh I
want to marry you blah blah and she
comes down and she starts working for
him and she's not even getting paid her
Fair cut it doesn't matter if she comes
out on social media says oh no like
we're cool everything especially if
they're still working in the industry
those statements explicitly called out
in Romanian law are not used to clear
the charges of sex trafficking they're
irrelevant okay so let me go through
your points might be a while right so
first things first in terms of the
property point right so again this is
the issue where you've
what what happened was Andrew has
explained this in long form and he did
explain that look I the way I see it is
in a traditional religious view so what
happens is in the abrahamic religions
you have a scenario where the man gives
the the father gives the woman away the
Visa diary where you give a payment to
the father and then he passes over now
you may agree or disagree with that but
that's the perspective now I understand
um in this liberal Western World why
that would be a problem and because in
Liberal Western ideology in reality it's
the man who's the property of the woman
because what happens is in this yeah I'm
about to explain to your destiny so
because in this world in this Western
liberal ideology you have a scenario
where basically the the man when he
marries the woman he makes a contract
and the contractor exists that he
promised to be monogamous
but the woman doesn't make the same
agreement because what happens is if the
man
cheats on the woman
he loses 50 of everything
if if she leaves him if the woman
cheats on the man he has to either
accept it or he has to basically divorce
her and then he loses 50 of everything
so in so I understand why that would be
a problem because in Western liberalism
the man is the property of the woman in
terms of um the um
you said I I you said I don't I I you
said I don't think but it doesn't matter
what you think about this this issue
it's about what actually happened and in
terms of the issue you've got a scenario
where
there's not enough evidence to prosecute
or convict that's what the judge said
because what you're trying to say is
guess what there may be a plethora of
evidence but they've not given it to us
so guys there is enough evidence to
prosecute but it's just hidden away but
that's not the that's not what's
happening what's happening is they're
looking for the evidence to take the bar
from Reasonable Suspicion to the fact
that they know that they'll be able to
convict Beyond reasonable doubt that's
why they're looking that's why the boys
and the two girls are in prison because
they're looking for this evidence now
that's the other point now you said what
should be happening is and I think you
made a fair point you said guess what
what should be happening is the
prosecutor should be looking looking at
the accounts of the girls looking at the
deer information looking at how much
money's going to count and then they'll
find out I agree with that
and that will and if they do that then
we'll have a better idea of what's
happened but up to now let's it's less
it's either they've done it and that
doesn't give us the information that
they want right and hence why they're
still looking for more evidence
that's the first possibility or the
second purpose possibility that they've
not even realized about doing it and
they probably should have consulted with
you and they need to do it for over the
next four months that's that's the other
point
in terms of the CCTV
the problem is because you you and I
explain to you this is contravention of
international law and Romanian law to
explain to you is article five one
article
and article 100 sorry article 99 and
article 100 say it's an article 99 says
this the victim
and the suspect should be able to
present evidence to to fight you know to
the to the prosecutor in terms of
positive evidence in their care so
they've contravened that
article 100 that the um the prosecute
sorry the defendant should be able to
provide evidence that basically
strengthens his case so that the
prosecutor can think twice whether to
prosecute or not so these have been
contravened and this was my example
because I know you wanted examples of
international law being contravened but
it's not just international law it's not
European largest because remember
European Lobby is incorporated into
Romanian law so it's both
um in terms of the what's up so again
you got a scenario where like I said to
you you have a scenario where the
WhatsApp messages have only been given
in Snippets and the whole entirety
hasn't been given so again those should
be given in this episode again contrary
to those articles that I mentioned they
should all be given so that a person can
have a full basis of understanding of
what exactly is going on and the last
point
you mentioned that according to Romanian
law a victim and can you kind of a
scenario where the victim can sense and
is still trafficking how do you know
that the reason you know that the reason
you know that is because you have a
psych evaluation to be able to determine
if that person has been brainwashed or
the Stockholm syndrome for that person
I've explained to you already
the women who they claiming are
brainwashed haven't had a psychopath how
can you make it how can I speak to you
and then I say your your your your
wife's brainwashed that's illogical I
need to speak to her your wife and then
make a psychology a psychological
deduction and say that is she
brainwashed or not and finally you
haven't answered this question I've
explained it that when it comes to the
rape allegations when it comes to the
human trafficking allegations the judge
has said that the evidence you've
provided me is reasonable suspicion but
you need to go back and find enough
evidence so we can prosecute and convict
they're looking for that evidence and
they've not found it your argument that
guess what they might have it hidden
somewhere they might use it later that
is
that that that that's illogical because
the whole point is they're looking for
it to be able to now prosecutive that's
why they've got the guys in there unless
you're saying they basically again
trying to torture the guys keep them in
there even though they have the evidence
keep them in there for the full 180 days
and the girls should break them and then
use that later
okay so the first thing I just have a
simple question which so I'm not a big
religious guy okay I grew up Catholic
but what do I know okay which of the
traditional abrahamic religious uh
religious
um practices allow you to have your
wives webcaming
foreign
so in terms of which Abraham abrahamic
religion is wrong according to all of
the ethical paradigms I think is wrong
so I think the entire industry okay let
me finish now because you asked me a
question I can't give a half answer so
the entire industry which is the webcam
industry whether it's the only fans
industry whether it's the tick tock
industry whether it's Instagram any kind
of sexual sexual exploitation of men and
some of it is extra exploitation of
women as well is is not allowed at all
but in terms of what because what you're
trying to make it look like is guess
what he's following religion in this and
he's not following in this but my point
is this we don't know because when you
look at his views even in 2020 when it
came to some of his views about Islam
they were horrendous and he then
apologized and said look I have these
views and I no longer have these views
so we can only make someone's a
determination on somebody's ethical
framework on that given point because
people's ethics in my ethics have
changed out you know you you change in
terms of yeah okay so okay so so I don't
know why we would ever appeal to any
traditional statement then that Andrew
Tate has made because you just admitted
that he made horrible statements on
Islam in 2020 maybe 2021 I don't know
when he converted but I'm not going to
then fall back on his traditional
religious statements to defend earlier
points in time when you yourself said he
had made horrible statements on Islam
interview it sounds reason are you sure
and I've seen the Piers Morgan interview
and I don't think that there was any
Redemption to be found for entertain in
that interview I don't think that you
can say he was being traditional when he
talks about owning women and then using
them to webcam I don't think there's
anything traditional about that there's
certainly nothing in Christianity about
that I seriously doubt that anybody in
Islam would be protecting that no no no
no let me finish let me finish okay yeah
um there's nothing traditional about
that so I'm not going to evaluate any of
his statements as a traditionally
religious statement I'm going to
evaluate them for what they are
um I don't know what the side tangent
about how like if a woman owns a man
because a if a man cheats on her she
gets half or whatever
um first of all like even alimony is
awarded in very rare cases you're
talking about like exceptional
circumstances where biggest states are
being separated and when they are being
separated it's based on the accumulation
of wealth within that marriage now if
the man is accumulating most of the
wealth then yeah he might be subject to
lose it based on the agreement of the
marriage but if a woman is accumulating
most of the world then she says who's
accumulated Muslim wealth and marriages
right now it's men thank you but the law
doesn't say a man loses half and a woman
owns the man
I don't care about the implication I'm
talking about the law that's great but
I'm just talking about the law so the
law says that once you are married as a
couple you begin to accumulate and
accrue things as a couple and then when
you split depending on the agreements
you have in place depending on what the
arrangement of their marriage was you
are generally entitled to split those
things 50 50 between both parties now if
one side has earned more than the other
of course it's gonna feel like they're
losing more but that is the legal
arrangement of marriages as they exist
in the west if you don't like it that's
fine get a prenup um foreign
there's not enough evidence to convict
and you're saying that's not how um you
keep saying that they don't have
evidence to do the charges right now it
might be the case that they feel like
they have a strong case they feel like
they have enough to do some kind of
charge now but they want to dig farther
and see how much they can find before
they actually go to court if they were
to try to charge them right now on just
sex trafficking maybe it's the case that
in one or two months they could have dug
up more evidence and maybe they could
have had something related to tax fraud
as well but they need time to find that
information now in Romanian Criminal
Courts you can detain somebody for up to
180 days depending on the type of
criminal conviction or charge they might
be facing and in these cases the charges
are exceptional it's sex trafficking
it's rape I think that uh organization a
criminal organization or arrangement of
criminal organization is one of the
charge as well in these cases when these
are the charges facing them they have
the right to detain these people and to
search more to finish what they want to
accumulate for or what they want to
recruit before they start to bring these
charges to the people they don't have to
charge them immediately right when they
have something that's just not the case
so you keep you keep saying this line
that well the judges said they don't
have enough to convict they don't have
enough to charge why would the
prosecution hide something it might be
the case that the prosecution is just
doing more research to see what they
actually want to bring when they've done
all their research rather than charging
the first thing they have that they
think will stick and the judge himself
has said while you well you are
correctly saying um that he's saying
they're not looking for enough evidence
to bring a conviction or aware charge
yet he's saying that there is a lot of
evidence that points in that direction
and that's why he has denied repeatedly
the appeals of the Tates to be released
from prison
um when you talk about statements from
like suspects or whatever the reason why
the suspect statements don't matter it's
because sex trafficking can never be
done with the consent of a victim it
might be the case that a victim says oh
no I consent oh no it's okay but if you
dig up the evidence that they were
initially misled or that they were
coerced in some Manner and they continue
to work for the person it doesn't matter
if they're going to say oh no it's okay
it looks like in the west you can't sell
yourself into slavery much the same you
can't consent to being sex trafficked it
doesn't matter what the victim says at
that point
um
yeah that's all I got for that
Okay so
I've got my list okay go ahead yeah yeah
okay right so okay so in terms of what
you said about PS about the Traditional
Values because what you did was you said
guess what I explained Traditional
Values in terms of the prop the property
argument and then you said guess what
over actually needs to apply to
everything no I just in in the PS Morgan
interview he'd already converted Islam
so you saw that direction where he was
basically changing his ethical framework
and so
that is that is covers that issue in
terms of
um
accrue in money what you said where men
can earn more
what you're saying is it's all about the
law but the thing is that what the Lord
does is right now it has a scenario
where it severely impacts men hence why
I said man a property and in terms of uh
talking about marriage because I did see
a podcast from yesterday where you
claimed that um 40 of sorry 60 of men uh
receive custody that's inaccurate I did
look into it because when I heard it I
was shocked it's actually 80 of women
received custody so that was inaccurate
um
um and there's some data since 65 but
it's actually 80 of women so 20 of men
only receive custody
um
so if you can provide us with your uh
data because I've looked into the
significant amount of research in terms
of what I said sure um and I'm let me
finish sorry
um now you said guess what did so I my
argument was this they've not got enough
evidence to prosecute and convict the
judges told them go back and look for
more evidence your your argument is
maybe they're looking for other things
maybe they might find other things maybe
they're looking for tax it doesn't
matter what you think it doesn't matter
what maybe is it matters what it is
right now right now the judge has said
there's not enough evidence you need to
find the evidence so whatever all the
evidence that they're presented and they
presented the whatsapps they presented
the psych reports and they presented the
witness statements that isn't enough so
your argument about maybe could be
possibly irrelevant
um
kind of agree my own writing but anyway
another point is
um again you said
um about 180 days the same thing you
said it might be the case so again
irrelevant now what you said is another
point you said there's a lot of evidence
look that is inaccurate what the judge
said is because this is very important
that viewers understand the thresholds
right now there's not a lot of evidence
what that's been presented to the judge
only meets Reasonable Suspicion so
you've got Reasonable Suspicion here I
don't want to give a percentage because
then I'll get into a debate our
percentages but as a viewer you can
understand maybe it's like 20 30
whatever it may be that's just a one a
percentage I made up a reasonable
suspicion then in a civil court you have
something called balance of probability
so you need to prove something by 51
right and then you got something which
is beyond Reasonable Doubt what is that
percentage 70 1890 but it needs to be
beyond beyond Reasonable Doubt like if
you you know you the a reasonable person
won't be able to doubt it so that's the
level in needs to get to in terms of
evidence So when you say there's a lot
of evidence no there's some evidence
which is reasonable reasonable uh uh
um you're saying it has to be to that
level in order for them to detain him
for this long no no I'm saying in order
to prosecute and convict it has to be at
that level because you have to convict
based on that and they know they haven't
got that so they need to meet they need
to take the evidence from here and take
it all the way up to here before they
can actually convict our prosecutors so
do you know what level that roughly they
have to be at in order to detain someone
for that long Reasonable Suspicion which
is very low I like the Contour yeah
which is which is Romanian which is what
I said which I had a problem with the
Romanian law but it is remaining low
um
the other point is this you keep mention
consent
and the problem is this with your with
what you're arguing I can say you've
been human trafficked and and you'll be
like look you got transported here
you're brainwashed uh Pearl brainwashed
you and you're like no no I never
brainwashed you know she never
brainwashed probably like I never
brainwashed her and then I'll just speak
to the um
um the producer and he'll be like yeah
yeah you know he he he was brainwashed
and then that's at your brainwash no the
way I find out is someone's brainwashed
this I will speak to you and you've not
answered this point and I will make a
psych evaluation on you and I will say
based on this evaluation this person
does look like they're being brainwashed
this person does look like they got
stuck on a syndrome and then we can do
it because if you're going to live in a
society where I can randomly just say
this person brainwashed that person
brainwash just based on a random person
saying it or someone who knows you
saying it that is a scary scary Society
to live in that's a totalitarian society
and that's why I always say as much as
if you don't like Andrew te or you love
Andrew te or whatever it may be always
remember whenever you're making an
argument
them arguments could be used against you
because whenever they use Draconian
measures against someone they always use
it against someone you don't like and
then they apply to everybody else that's
very important to realize
and so that's the whole basis that you
can claim that anyone's brainwashed
you've still not answered my question
about the uh contravention of the
international laws and EU laws which
aside well nobody has claimed that there
have been besides their lawyers nobody
is challenging any of Iranian laws in
European courts right because I don't
think that there has been a problem with
how Romanian conductive legal system in
the European courts when you try to say
that uh you could just say that I'm
brainwashed and pearl trafficked me you
could say that if you went through and
you dug through our text messages and
pearl is saying Stephen come to London I
want to marry you please and then I show
up and she's like you're gonna suffer
through six of my shows now and uh maybe
we'll get married by the end and also
I'm gonna you know like then you would
have a case you would have a foundation
for it but it's not just a matter of I'm
saying you're brainwashed therefore you
are therefore you were trafficked that's
not equivalent at all here right what
we're looking at is a pattern of Tate
communicating with girls promising to
marry them getting into relationship
with them and then bring them over and
then having them do sex work that's
what's being alleged here and a victim
statement saying like oh no like uh I I
you really did love me and that's not
what's happening that's not enough to
overturn it so if you wanted to make the
the comparison to me and pearl you would
have to find some crazy messages from
her to me that I don't believe exists
that show that she's promising me some
kind of like relationship or something
that's getting me to fly out here and do
content that's what would make it
equivalent the actual evidence the
actual message is afterwards
um when you keep saying here that the
judge has said that there's not enough
evidence um to convict I don't believe
the judge has made that statement what
the judge has said is you do not require
enough evidence for a conviction you
only need enough to bring a charge
forward and the prosecution right now is
in the final stages of their
investigation of doing that now you can
say that they're holding him for
whatever reason they want or they you
know maybe they don't have the evidence
and they're just bullshitting their way
through it but if that's the case they
were already arrested and remaining
before and they weren't held for that
long right where they're already
released so it seems like they do have
some internal standard they're trying to
meet to have a compelling amount of
evidence to lock them up and finish an
investigation and like I said all we
could do is wait and see what the final
results of that turn out to be if it
turns out to be that they didn't collect
anything compelling then I imagine
hopefully they release what they have or
whatever we say there was enough and
then they walk and then that's it but if
they do have enough then it moves
forward to the to the trial stage and I
just don't know why why you would ever
feel confident enough to say that
evidence doesn't exist they're not going
to happen there's no way when things are
being leaked by the prosecution like
every two days every every new day we
get something else I think geez shoot I
should have read this but I'm pretty
sure like two days ago there's literally
just something new
um that was released about a couple of
the new victims or one of the new
victims that came forward but I mean new
stuff is coming forward all the time
um when you can I finish my up for you
yeah okay you mentioned that 60 I also I
do think it's telling that there's a
weird when I try to evaluate the Andrew
Tate stuff I'm not trying to do this
weird like East versus West Islam
whatever I'm just looking at the facts
the case that's all I generally care
about I think it's interesting that
there are so many of these points you're
bringing up relating to like western
eastern gynocentric you know females
owning men uh you brought up that 60
versus 80 of who's winning custody cases
the claim that I made was that when men
fight for custody they win 60 of the
time I believe that women win 80 to 90
of the time but that's because men
usually don't fight for custody but when
they do fight for custody they tend to
win 60 of the time those are the numbers
that I'm familiar with when you say that
laws favor men versus women when it
comes to divorcing it just favors
whoever's made most of the money and in
this female dominated world as women are
earning more and more money maybe when
men will rise up and when we divorce
women maybe we'll start taking more from
them than they take for us from us but
it just matter the only thing that
matters is who's earned more money not
whether you're not you're a man or woman
and then for the final thing the first
thing you brought up was he was changing
his framework on Piers Morgan why would
I care about him changing his framework
on Piers Morgan when the statements that
he's made about owning women were done
in the past when he owned his sex
trafficking business it might be the
case that as of the past year he's
become a good devout Muslim he's he
follows the teaching of Islam and all of
that he's doing that great that's fine I
don't care that's not when he ran his
business he ran his business like five
years ago
would you agree with what he said on the
psych evaluation that those girls should
have had a psych evaluation themselves I
don't know specifically how the
psychologist is uh extrapolating to The
Other Women I do know that the two that
go on to defend Tate literally have
tattoos of him on their body so I don't
know if they would be and I'm pretty
sure they still work in the industry so
I don't know if those are going to be
like the most exonerating types of
evidence but I mean if the psych if the
psych evals were the only thing that was
keeping them in the Romanian courts I
think I would probably disagree with the
judge's evaluation there but those
aren't the only things only holding him
in the court the prosecution has linked
a ton of different types of text
messages showing Criminal Intent showing
organization of um of the criminal
organization showing threats made to
some of the talent showing different
messages where Andrew Tate is promising
marriage if a woman moves to Romania um
so to say that the prosecution rests
solely on that psychevel I don't believe
that's fair
okay go ahead okay so first thing is in
terms of the contravention of the
international law you didn't give no
answer all you said is I don't think
it's a problem it doesn't matter what
you think it's about whether they're
contravened or not the second thing is
in terms of
um relationship again so what you're
doing is you're basically saying because
I give the analogy about you impel so
what you're basically saying is if
someone's in a relationship vis-a-vis
that means that the human traffic no
those women
clearly based on the leaked documents
that you are referring to went were in
love with tear went to Winter
um Romania on their own violation and
then they made the decision based on
consent even the BBC woman literally
said I made the decision based on my own
choice and my own decision what your sin
is guess what they were brainwashed and
I just said to you but anyway you've
conceded it you said that the psych
report is unacceptable that happened and
in terms of the psych report
but you're saying again I don't think
this is the problem your whole argument
is about what you think it doesn't
matter what you think
what the judges said is there was three
important level there was three aspects
of the evidence that were important in
order to make a determination in terms
of rape allegation do you know what the
two evidences are it's only the witness
statement and the psych report so it's
50 of the evidence because a witness
statement and the psychopath are equally
weighted and it's the statement of the
woman in terms of the older women being
brainwashed
it's three so it's the witness statement
it's the psych report and finally it's
the uh evidence that's been leaked and
this is the issue the evidence that's
being leaked is weak like when we see
when you look at the evidence it does
not demonstrate what they've been
charged for it's so weak it's Snippets
of information and that's what my
argument is that based on the evidence
that we have right now and the judge
agrees with me so based on the leaks
that evidence isn't enough to prosecute
or convict so that's the point so you're
right we're getting leaks all the time
and yet we've not got a diamond leak so
this is the problem we've not got
anything damning that says it the other
point you made is what you know in terms
of we're talking about five years ago
again that's incorrect we're not talking
about five years ago maybe we're talking
about five years ago in terms of the
YouTube clips that you're interested in
but I already explained to you that's
irrelevant and I think you've finally
you admitted that it's irrelevant wait
when was this camping business they're
not being charged for five years ago
they've been charged for the last year
and a half yeah but we were talking
about in the context
so they're not even being charged with a
common business what they've been
charged for is only fans and Tick Tock
yeah and when did he do his chemic
business when did he start his come in
business yeah well I'm not looking at
that's not relevant because no no
because what's relevant no no that's not
relevant because what because again what
you are looking at is social media your
whole thing is trial by social media
everything on social media convicts him
I'm saying it doesn't matter what social
media says let's look at what's actually
happening what's actually happening is
he's been charged for allegations from
mid 2021 till mid 2022 it's that year or
year and a half in that year and year
and a half he is did not do the cam
business the court documents say it's um
Tick Tock and only fans
and so when you are referring to five
years ago that's irrelevant so what and
what I'm saying is it doesn't matter if
he's a good Muslim or a bad Muslim
that's not relevant to me I'm trying to
explain to you the reason why he used
the terminology of property now you're
saying he's a contradiction why is he
using the term property
and and then he's having a webcam
business so if he was using the term
property a year ago and he's using the
uh let's say a year ago yeah and he's
used and is doing the web I only fans
and
um what you call it was a tick tock what
all that demonstrates is that he's got a
contradiction in his views and I can
tell you now most people do have
contradiction their ideas what views
thoughts ideologies I accept that's a
contradiction but in terms of that
specific point he is appealing to
Traditional Values even though I agree
webcam business isn't
um
again look you keep saying I don't think
I don't think it's that but look the
judge already said the standard
misreasonable suspicion look for more
evidence that's the reason they've
detained them no one's denying that so
you know when you keep saying I I don't
think I know you need to say that
because you need this debate to continue
going and you need to try and argue your
point but in reality that's not what it
is you have to look at what the the data
is and what the information is and
that's literally what we've got the
information according to everyone
according to the judge is that it's not
enough
um
you mentioned that um
yeah I've answered I've answered yeah
you I I don't know what to say you keep
saying like the judge agrees with me
when clearly he doesn't because he has
denied the repeals and continued to
detain them so what do you think because
he believes that the prosecution has
provided sufficient evidence to show
that there are what level of evidence
the judge has said I'm just saying that
you know if you wanted to screen
yourself okay well maybe the judge
doesn't disagree with me but it's
strange that you would pick and choose
the job what level of evidence just
answer it what level of evidence that
there's a reasonable suspension we agree
that's how the Romanian criminal court
system works no that's what Andrew Tate
moves specifically to Romanians he said
that he liked the way their courts
worked and he moved there and now he's
over there now if you if you say if you
say if you use a question no you can't
you can't after I'm done okay you said
you said very specifically you said very
specifically that it's about I feel I
think I feel I think that's every
statement you've made in regards to them
uh contributing with uh international
law nobody the the international courts
aren't saying the Romania system is in
violation of international law no
European commission has said that the
remaining courts are in violation of
international law and the judge himself
is referencing international law when
he's giving reasons in his own document
for why they're remaining locked up so
if you want to say the judge agrees with
you I don't know what you're agreeing
with maybe you just want to pick and
choose things that the judge says you
agree with um I understand we're kind of
circling the drain on that am I going
back and forth but yeah no that does
confuse me so if the judge agrees with
you then why is he locked up still Yeah
so basically that's the reason why
they've taken on Tina glandian because
notice that the judge agrees with me
about the level of evidence okay so what
the level of evidence is this is that
and and Destiny agrees as well because
he said his Reasonable Suspicion my next
question to Destiny was going to be
destiny do you agree that the level of
evidence is renewable Reasonable
Suspicion and they need to find no more
much more evidence to bridge that Gap to
be honest Reasonable Doubt so that was
gonna be my question so if you can
answer that reasonable I don't know
Reasonable Doubt is what you prove in a
court to convict somebody exactly
exactly that's not what you need to
bring charges against somebody though
of course you do because if you do if
you if you if you when you're when
you're bringing charges you would not
bring charges based on weaker evidence
and then hope that you bridge the gap
during trial you I know you've got the
sufficient evidence hence why the uh
allegations in the United Kingdom were
not taken forward because they found
that the women were colluding and so
they knew that they wouldn't be able to
get Beyond Reasonable Doubt now in terms
of
um so that was that in terms of uh but I
think Destiny agrees I think I'm I'm not
understanding where where it is I think
he said I think but when you say Beyond
Reasonable Doubt yeah that's in my mind
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt is what you
have to prove in front of a jury that's
right yeah so when a prosecutor takes
the case to the call
he's not going to take he doesn't take
the case based on weak evidence he's not
like um 50 sure and hopefully I'll
Bridge the 30 40 capture in the trial no
of course he says he says look I've got
this I can actually connect Beyond
Reasonable Doubt let me take this and
that's why the prosecute and that's very
important for prosecutors because they
have a certain percentage that they've
got to meet so they know that the level
of evidence needs to be that level
before they take it to trial yeah so
they so yeah so they right now they have
a reasonable suspicion and because of
the nature of the crimes in the Romanian
criminal court system they're allowed to
detain them while they finish their
investigation we agree with this so far
right that's what they're allowed to do
in Romania the judge has looked at their
appeals he's looked at the evidence the
prosecution has submitted and he said
well you know I think there's enough
here to let the prosecution continue
their investigation and that's how the
Romanian criminal court system works now
you might feel like it's an
international law violation you might
cite article 99 and 100 and article 51
but none of the international courts
have thus far challenged uh the Romanian
Criminal Court proceeding so that is
your feeling as much as anything in here
might be my feeling
um you mentioned uh evidence relating to
women colluding in the UK on a rape
charge
um that's in dispute we don't know if
the women were colluding or not I
believe that the um prison I'm sorry the
police officer said that they didn't
like that when the two women were
texting each other I believe the women
said that we weren't um sure if we
should tell the police that he had
gotten us drunk beforehand and that the
police officers considered that
colluding now it could be the case that
the women are misleading their text
messages there or it could be the case
that the police officers aren't being
forthcoming with the text measure it's
hard to say because I haven't seen those
text messages myself but I think it's
not fair to just instantly claim they
were colluding I know that's what Tate
likes to say but Tate hasn't produced
any of those text messages either so all
I can go are by the statements of the
women of the same as the police
um in regards to that
um I when you when you bring up the the
rape allegations I now I remember
because you brought this up I'm pretty
sure it was yesterday didn't Romanian
authorities find that there were three
more rape allegations that had been
tried to have been filed in a local
Romanian police station and they ended
up not being followed up on because of
the two women that were arrested one of
which was a police officer is that not
the case that not just happened
yesterday
so I mean it seems like the prosecution
is still uncovering things and I mean
like I said we'll see in a month or two
or however long it takes them once they
finish their investigation what kind of
charges are brought forth but all we can
do is sit and wait
okay so just to summarize what you said
you agree that basically they're
unreasonable suspicion at the moment
they haven't got enough evidence to
prosecute or convict that was basically
my argument right at the beginning in
terms of international law let me let me
be clear what you keep saying is I think
I feel I believe I've been saying
international law that's a big
difference between what both me and you
doing in terms of why that hasn't been
highlighted well that's why they got
Tina glandian who is actually an expert
in international law and human rights
law and if the Rome if
if the Romanian system does not does not
basically follow what are the
regulations then I do believe that that
will be an Avenue that will take so
there's a reason why there's a human
rights lawyer that's now been included
into the team so and she's explained
that there is contravention but how you
find contravention is by applying and
make an application so that's that will
be the steps that they'll be taken so
yeah I've explained to you what the
contravention is and then I've explained
to you that in terms of the lawyer but
the difference between what I'm doing
and what you're doing is I've actually
cited law you're just saying I feel it's
all about feelings and emotions that's
basically what your arguments are
um
in terms of
um the British women incorrect the
British woman said themselves that the
pro CPS told them that because they were
colluding that's why they never took
their allegations forward but then the
women said guess what no no we weren't
we were including we were talking about
the um you know about the wine issue but
the women specifically said that the CPS
told them that is the reason why I
wasn't it wasn't taking forward because
of the voice message that they were
sending in terms of
um the four extra women it was actually
for extra women that who have made
claims again none of that has been
presented to the court none of that has
been verified that has been stayed in
the newspaper but again I can't comment
on that because we haven't got enough
information about that we haven't got
enough allegations on that it and
they're not rape allegations they
basically again saying that he's been a
bit again when you look at the
allegations they get very very weak they
do not amount to human trafficking and
that's my point all of these allegations
they don't amount of human trafficking
and you and we know that because why
don't they want to include the CCTV you
know why they don't want includes the
CCTV I know know why they don't want to
include the CCTV because the CCTV will
demonstrate that actually these women
had freedom of movement freedom of a
freedom of doing what they want and it
would give a great window into seeing
that and hence why they're not including
it because they know they're dumb is the
case and that's why they're not
including it into the uh prosecution
evidence
and sorry in the last bit the psych
report you've not you're not again oh no
so you already conceded that sorry so
the um do you think that the
international law will change
um or do you think that Romanian law
will change after this case
If This truly is a violation it's a very
good question that's that's what the
reason international law that we very
recently Romanian law changed because
what happened was Romanian law had it in
there where women weren't among allowed
to work as long hours as men
international law uh uh a violate
international law and very recently it
was changed so yes that's the best
that's the reasons that's the reason we
have ill on international law so do you
think that the law will change after the
state case about this issue yeah so this
issue is that they've just not applied
the law so they they own this is part of
their opinion no no no no this is my
favorite opinion it's your opinion no no
this is not an opinion I'm saying they
already have this in Romanian law no the
problem is you're saying the judge and
all the court cases are violating their
own law right now that's an opinion
that's a feeling that you have no no
it's not a feeling an opinion
the article that I have cited are part
of Romanian law so what I'm trying to
say is that has been overlooked by the
judge so he should look into it so maybe
he will look into it the next one but
the point is the judge had overlooked it
and that's incorrect because you wanted
me to cite examples of where
international law has been contravened
sure so that's why that's in your
opinion that's all that is it's not an
opinion the judge is the judge it's the
legal system you feel like it doesn't
adequately addressed the international
lawsuit that's right John obviously
disagrees with you that's your opinion
though I don't know why you why you
think that that's like a fact that you
can State obviously different people you
probably have an opinion that the
Patriot Act or something also violates
International laws but that would be an
opinion so so I I I I know that the
Patriot actors in Internet doesn't
violate International laws and neither
does the Romanian system I'm saying ish
what should happen is in terms of the
Patriot Act in terms of the the same
rules in the United Kingdom terrorism
act in terms of the Romanian system in
the 180 days I'm saying that I had I I
said it right at the beginning that that
my argument based on that isn't based on
law so that is my opinion that that
should be changed because I think that's
unethical that you can detain someone
especially when most of these people who
are being detained from Minority
communities sure and you say for the
Romanian law you think it's a statement
of fact that the judge is violating
their own laws that whole that whole
process right now everybody look look
that's not how law works this when you
when you if you think that the law works
that a judge basically applies certain
laws in a scenario and doesn't either
consider because that actually happens
just sometimes don't consider certain
laws and that can be an oversight or it
could be that the judge
doesn't agree with it that could have
happened as well so I'm not saying that
that the judge did it on purpose is
possible it was just an oversight or it
could be that the test legal team didn't
even present it that could be it as well
but and that's why they've got Tina
glandian in the in in the foreign she's
not their lawyer though right isn't she
just her U.S lawyer she's not even the
one that's allowed inside the jail so if
they were serious about getting somebody
to challenge this on like an
international right stage is she
bringing an international Case forward
like she I thought that she was just the
U.S representative they have she's not
part of the Romanian legal team so I
think you just hit onto a very important
point so Tina glandian can't represent
they can't represent them inside the
Romanian call but she can represent them
in the international stage so yeah if
this went further into the international
State she would be able to represent
them and
based on that she should be allowed to
see them so again that's another
contravention don't you think that's
unacceptable that a lawyer who we Ascend
there's a possibility that these
articles have been contravened is
they're not allowed to see her clients
to be able to mount and understand their
position and their arguments and amount
that defense in the international call
do you think that is the actual
violation of you no I've never heard of
that it's this is that if I get arrested
here in London for doing something that
I can necessarily demand a U.S lawyer
that flies over to here and has rights
to access me in prison or anything else
I've never heard that as an
international law before that's a word
no no no no you have an access to your
legal counsel is an interesting access
to their Romanian they have access to
their Romanian legal council for the
case within Romania if this case was to
be taken to the international stage they
would need access to the international
lawyer which would be this person and
they're not the international stage yet
how does a case go into an international
stage you basically retain someone they
speak to you you build your case and
then you mount it what are you talking
about that's literally what happens so
basically in your mind what happens is
you you own your attention is only made
when you make the application that's
literally not how law works that's
literally not how the system works what
you're talking about my guess would be
that in the middle of your guess is okay
the fact of the matter is is in the
middle of an investigation for another
case you probably couldn't bring an
international Case at the very same time
I don't know yours is a fact well I'm
I'm saying prove it's a factor I've
explained to you how the law Works
you're saying that is she even retained
for an international Case right now has
she filed an international Case I've
just explained to you so now so
everything you're saying is an opinion
you have no you have no basement even
believe that she will file internet you
have no idea about that I've just
explained to you that there's a reason
why that there's a human rights to the
lawyer involved there's a reason why
she's actually stated human rights laws
within within the public sphere and what
I'm saying is it could be that they
don't file it the pro issue is this
because that actually happens the whole
point is she should be having access to
her and to her clients to be able to
determine if the case is going to be
strong enough because what if they
reveal something to her and then she
thinks that's not a good hour haven't
you go what if they don't want to go
down the Avenue and that's why you need
to have access to your lawyers that's
right I don't think I don't think that
in every country I don't think that you
can demand have an international lawyer
step in when you're in the middle of a
local uh or a local corporate in every
country well not in every country but
anytime I just Googled it says the right
requires the accused to have access to a
lawyer at all stages of criminal
proceedings including the initial period
of police detention questioning and
investigation of lawyer yes they have
that to their Romanian lawyer but what
he's saying is they also have a U.S
lawyer that they feel should be able to
come in and represent them from an
international account you should have
access to all your lawyers that's I'm
not a show about arguing this like this
if if your argument was this if my
argument was this she should they should
have access to the international law
Athena for the Romanian case you are
right I I and that's that's why I never
made that argument because that's true
and if you want to make the argument
that if they file an international case
they should have access to an
international law then sure that's fine
too but my understanding is Tina has not
been retained to file an international
Case yeah she might talk about
International legal violation or
whatever but of course she's going to
say that she's their lawyer that's her
job she's supposed to say whatever she
can to make them look good but if she
wants to go and actually file an
international case then we would be
having a different conversation the
Romanian authorities were saying you
can't talk to these people uh because
we've got them in our prisons right now
then that probably wouldn't be do you
accept that you're going to retain a
lawyer and that that lawyer can act for
you before you make an application
um sure but I don't know if that lawyer
should have access to you while you're
in foreign
education if she doesn't have access to
what why don't you make a phone call
write a letter she's make she's got
right from these guys right right come
on man when you when you want to need to
talk yeah so that even a phone call
would be access to your lawyer like what
yes so yeah haven't they communicated
with her
um I don't know about in terms of phone
call but you should be able to have
access to your lawyer so what's up how
did they retain her if they're not able
to communicate with her clearly they
have communicated with her mind
understanding she's not allowed into the
prison to actually see them that was the
issue that she had is she actually I
think she flew to Romania and she went
with the remote and they didn't let her
into the president so again she should
be allowed access because if you're
gonna now she hasn't filed an
international Case status she hasn't
filed that case then let me explain she
should have access to them because when
she goes and sees them in the in the in
the prison one of the things that may
surmises because for example we don't
know if he's in solitary confinement it
could I never brought it up because we
don't know it could be it may not be we
don't know the prison conditions it
could be bad it could be okay she should
be she when she goes in and sees them
she'll be able to observe that and then
based on that if the conditions are bad
if he's in solitary confinement you can
that's another contravention of
international law you could then
more significant another additional
arguments in the international sphere so
it's imperative that you can have access
to your lawyer because that's how you
can make in that deduction is this your
illegal factors
yes it says the HR committee has
consistently held that the iccp pr
article 14 requires that the accused be
granted timely access to council unless
it can be shown that there are
compelling reasons to restrict access
um so like wouldn't it like it
because that kind of backs up what he's
saying no well there's the unless
there's compelling reason to restrict
access right
part of the legal system is going to
have a lot of discretion right even
things you're saying like probable cause
or or even beyond that Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt right so if I was going
to file like if I'm just thinking if I
was going to file an international com
like complaint like don't you have to
meet with your lawyer I don't think
they're not going to file an
international plan that's just what
people like cameras saying to run
defense for him nobody's filing an
international complaint how do you know
what I'm saying I'm saying
hypothetically if he does yeah if you
wanted to file an international
so if you wanted to take this to like
the world stage like don't you think he
should be able to meet with his lawyer
yeah if he if they wanted to
legitimately bring a case in front of
the EU or whatever yeah then I think you
should open right but you'd say like he
has to meet with them first right well I
don't know if he has to meet face to
face for that you don't think that would
be helpful I I don't know if that I
don't know what rights are necessarily
like if I get arrested in like let's say
let's say that I get a speeding ticket
here right let's say that I'm speeding
and then I go to jail right and I'm in
holding or whatever let me process my
stuff yet do I have a right to call a US
lawyer and say I want him to come here
and talk to me face to face because I'm
going to file an international case
against you guys I don't know if you if
that right is avoided to you always my
guess is going to be is that during this
detentionary period they probably don't
have that right afforded to them because
it's during this attention period And
before after or I guess when they say
really after they would have the right
to do that or if they actually start to
face charges or something if charges are
filed against them and now they're held
while they're awaiting trial they
probably would but for this point in
time they probably don't have the right
to that's that's inaccurate Destiny I
mean you are a good debate but the point
is the issue is this if you are gonna
file any kind of a case irrespective of
his domestic or it's International you
need to have access to your lawyer for a
domestic case you have access to your
domestic lawyers when it's international
Case it acts as the international
lawyers when you're giving your prison a
ticket fine that's a domestic issue so
you'll be accessed to domestic lawyers
if I was basically
um let's say I was um you know my rights
were taken away from me from an
international perspective let's say I
was Assange or something then I would
need access to my International lawyer
so that's literally how it works you
need to see them face to face well you
should be able to see them face to face
I'll explain yeah because for certain
things you would need to see them face
to face yes you do because
you don't you don't need face-to-face
so in a telephone call everybody knows
it could be tapped there's a lot of
issues that you can have that where you
don't want to send a telephone call
that's why you need face-to-face access
so you can be able to converse on its
own ahead and you can mount a fair
defense that's the tenant of our of all
legal systems that you're not you that
you should not have a scenario where you
you but you could be self-incriminated
so I'm I'm not understanding why you're
not agreeing with this because I haven't
seen anything that's showing that this
is do you agree that much I haven't seen
anything this could be true do you agree
in a telephone call you it could be
tapped and then that could be
theoretically it could be sure and
that's why it face to face is important
sure but well you haven't proven that
they even have a desire to take this to
any International Court I've just
explained to you that they retained an
international lawyer I've explained to
you that International where she
livescal in the United States she does
and she also has she is on the UN
Council as well and she has un positions
has she represented any case in front of
an international court before well based
on her CVS I would assume there has but
haven't looked into okay so we don't
know because our last client was like
Jesse Smollett wasn't it it was yeah
okay so I don't know what internet so
when you say human rights that could
just be local criminal defense in the
United States but the the issue is this
she's
um she's talked about the human rights
violations right she is a human rights
lawyer international human rights lawyer
because you keep on making it sound like
a domestic and then the and then I've
decided certain articles that being
breached there's possible possible oh
this could be breached like solitary
confinement
um poor prison conditions which will
reach easy uh European call of Human
Rights
and So based on that they should have
faced as you agree because face to face
is more important based on tapping in
these type of things what we've already
explained it should they should have
face-to-face contact if after speaking
to her then she doesn't feel like that's
a viable uh defense or that she doesn't
feel less survival Avenue to go that's
fine but that's the whole reason you
retain lawyers your 10 lawyers they tell
you the strengths of weaknesses of going
down a certain Avenue and then you make
a decision
you mentioned international human rights
layer is there like a special license
you need to do like international law
can you just like pass the bar exam in a
state in the United States and now you
can do like International court cases in
front of the EU or is she actually
licensed as like an international lawyer
she is
yeah check it out I'm curious and then
secondly if we're so paranoid about the
telephone call being tapped couldn't a
face-to-face conversation be tapped as
well
that's possible but then at the same
time it's less likely hence why you have
face to face and there's a there's a
requirement that you basically answer I
agree there is a possibility less likely
it is less likely do you agree gender no
it is less likely I think that if
somebody's gonna tap a phone call in
today's day and age I'm pretty sure they
would just tap the room it wouldn't
surprise me if all of those rooms
recorded
do you know if she's is she like an
internationally licensed and to work as
an internet oh you want me to look up
the actual yeah I'm just curious to the
actual Tina um Tina what's her name
glendian grandyan
the end uh what what is why oh should we
move the argument or not sorry
let's wait with baited breath cool
um Tina glandon is a U.S legal advisor
who's a partner wait hold on so you want
to know like what specific I'm just
curious if you want to know this
international law because she does she
does she does I mean you can check it
later but she does I'm just Wikipedia
I'm sure it'll say it so she's a U.S
legal advisor who's a partner with the
fur Law Firm
how to say this garago they're gonna
make fun of me garagos and giragos okay
yeah
and people can check that out anyway
it's online
um I think I think I highlighted one of
my of one of my summer I highlighted
down has she's she is so do you guys
um
because one of the questions I had was
Andrew has Andrew Tate snitched on
himself and admitted to being guilty in
Hustler's university courses and I know
you guys touched on that a bit earlier
but
um it seems like you guys almost agree
that it could have been in Grandeur but
then you kind of were going back and
forth I personally think he has but his
issue is that that hasn't been the
evidence of some brought in front of the
court so far I don't know what the
prosecution is ultimately going to end
up bringing up sometimes these
investigations start small and they end
up sprawling back to a lot of things but
you couldn't convict Andrew Tate based
on what he said on social media that can
only be a starting point for an
investigation if you find something then
you maybe you know bring charges for it
but you can't just convict them based on
the course okay so you guys so we we
agree on that but my only question two
is Destiny do you agree that if there's
a scenario that what he said online
is different to the allegations that can
be used
what if what So based on what he said
online can never be used against him
that would only be a tool for
investigators to further dig into what
he said so he agrees online stuff is not
and then you sort of agree on the psych
report too right uh I would have to see
specifically why she's extrapolating
that to the other victims I don't
remember her rationale for why she uh
could make claims about the other uh
person's State of Mind
okay so yes or no so no
I'm agnostic on it right now okay well
yeah agnostics no no come on it's not
about winning the argument Destiny do
you think let's just let's frame it like
this then because you like you said you
need to look into it
if I did a psych report on Pearl based
on your statement do you think that's do
you think that's I wouldn't trust your
interpretation of it and I've only read
articles I'm not saying that I'm not
saying but I'm not even gonna follow the
analogy because like for instance the
analogy that you made about her
trafficking me just because I came here
to cam shows that you either have no
idea what trafficking is or what so I
know you've not proved it so I would
never no one has proved it yet if it was
proven that he would be convicted
exactly right because so in terms of I I
would have to I've only read articles
summarizing the second ever read the
secret for myself no no you don't
understand because you don't want to
answer it because it basically is it
because no it's a big defeat no no
because it's a defeater because the
whole point is this you're saying you've
not looked into it so you don't have the
knowledge about it I'm saying this
happened and I'm saying that's fine you
may not be able to take my word for it
my question to you is in the
hypothetical where person ear is deemed
a person by speaking to person a you
decide that person B has severe mental
issues always brainwashed or whatever it
may be do you think that's acceptable
depends on the commonalities that you
find between the two
how would you determine the
commonalities
um let's say you did a psych report on
somebody and let's say that you found
that this person worked for Andrew Tate
for five years this person had a tattoo
saying owned by Tate um this person was
recruited in a similar method and in
talking to them you realize like this
person's ability to even talk to who
talk to the um talk to person a not b
okay you talk to person a and you figure
all of that out about person a you're
like this person's ability to understand
the situation they've been in is
severely compromised and then you look
at person B and you start to find all of
those commonalities then it might be
fair to extrapolate how would you know
about them commonalities I don't know
what their what her method of data
collection that's the problem
okay well that's up to the prosecution
to present at trial I guess or present
to the judge yeah yeah so again another
problem well I don't know if it's a
problem or not we have it it depends on
if it goes to quarter it's a severe
problem bro come on what are you gonna
say if this goes to court and all of
this evidence plus more is brought in
front of the judge if this goes to court
and that that means there's Beyond
evidence which is beyond Reasonable
Doubt and then we look at the evidence
and it actually isn't some kind of like
you know where they're trying to
basically
do the guys over
then yeah I would accept it I would
accept any evidence so if there's
actually unequivocal evidence that these
guys have done these crimes of course we
would accept it that's that would be
illogical and you would be basically
um a Stan if you basically said no
matter what it's not for example I
didn't agree when a lot of the tear
people who send the audios were fake
because I knew they weren't but what
happened was there was a um in terms of
the vice piece but what actually
happened was it snipped out the other
side of the conversation so we don't
just make Arguments for the sake of it
I'm basing it solely on what I'm seeing
and I to be honest it looks like in this
whole thing I know you don't want to
accept certain points and you're doing
it quite
um with bearded um
um you know with it without finding hard
to agree
um in reality we kind of agree on
everything you agree that online stuff
can be used we agree the psych report is
problematic we agree right now there's
only reasonable suspicion they need to
find more evidence to get it Beyond
reasonable doubt we agree
um that the do you agree that CCTV
evidence should be included uh depends
on what charges they want to bring forth
do you think the CCTV evidence should be
included come on depends on what charges
human traffic can rip that's what I
don't know if that evidence is
dispositive
whether it's positive or negative do you
agree that that evidence would would
help find out that's why I said I don't
know if it's dispositive I don't know if
that evidence would go against claims
that they were being trafficked even
though the CCTV this is enough of the
life and of the entire facility to show
that like oh look they could leave at
any time were there people leaving the
premises that were employed for them
that were going in and out on that CTT
evidence well why don't the one include
it there's a reason they don't I'm
asking you was there sorry what was in
the CCTV footage that you think was so
important yeah included so according to
the witness Jasmine what the what is
actually shown in the CCTV evidence is
that they had freedom of movement that
the girl was basically jogging regularly
wait Freedom a moment how that for
example the woman was one of the victims
allegedly was what walk the running
Gotham runs on her own so okay
if she was part of the evidence was
leaked by The Prostitute
part of the evidence that was leaked by
the prosecution were text messages
saying that uh they were not allowed to
leave the premises that anytime they
wanted to leave they had to take one of
the two bodyguards or the um the one
lady the police officer I think lady
that was one of the texts yeah so again
so that what's up message you're talking
about was a snippet so if you look at it
it was like three texts and again so
that's the argument of the team that put
the whole what's up in because this
whole thing and everybody's in advice
everybody's in a BBC where you do
Snippets you can convict any I can
convict I'll give you the example where
I can connect you based on a snippet of
UC making that comment the issue is this
that you do the whole piece so if
someone saw your 10 hour podcast you
didn't say that you literally said the
opposite but if I snip that bit I could
say you know what you're a racist the
issue is this you give the whole of the
WhatsApp and then that's how you decide
in terms of the CCTV what it shows
according to Jasmine one of the alleged
victims who says I'm not a victim and
she's saying that it shows that one of
the alleged victims not her used to
regularly jog on her own that shows
freedom of movement one of the important
aspects of human trafficking is that you
don't have freedom of movement that
breaks one example of breaking the human
traffic allegation the finances breaks
the allegation of human trafficking the
reason I brought these up is because
they break the human traffic allegation
so the CCTV why is it the defense is so
adamant it should be included
sure so for finances
um I'm pretty sure that I don't know
what you're saying that anything for
proof of Finance is everything that has
ever been talked about or really seems
to show that the finance are in control
of the tapes that's what I've heard said
over and over and over again um in terms
of jogging um Jasmine might have stated
that somebody jogged but I don't know if
she said that under oath I don't know if
that's been entered into like an
official like witness statement now
maybe it will come when they go to the
court case where that'll actually be
argued about but my understanding is
that I don't think you have to publish
every single piece of evidence you have
before you go to trial for any country
ever right no no you may publicly
published I don't know if you have to
publicly publish for I imagine for the
court they're probably only pushing as
much as they need to so for the call you
need to give the evidence out of just
cited we didn't have all the evidence
yes every piece of evidence you found
you have to give to the job yeah if it's
just enough to show that you have a
reasonable suspicion that your
investigation will no because you need
to demonstrate to the judge that
basically you're gonna you have got the
evidence to demonstrate that what you've
got so in reality what they need to show
is that they've got evidence right now
because that shows that they will be
able to get Beyond Reasonable Doubt
because if the but the problem is they
haven't got the evidence right now so
that's why they're looking for evidence
so I don't think that we agree that they
don't need that evidence right you don't
need evidence to hold somebody for up to
180 days for that Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt sorry you don't need the evidence
yeah yeah I agree with that because for
the 180 days you need Reasonable
Suspicion what the judge said is when
you've given me the evidence that
evidence only amounts to Reasonable
Suspicion that's the reason they
investigating and looking unless they
basically basically violating their
rights and keeping them for 180 days to
break them before they say guess what
now we've got new evidence but in
reality we've seen it they're doing
raids they're finding new women them to
them for women that you refer to have
just been found very recently we have to
look at their backstory look at whether
it works so this is not information that
they held on to and then and then
thought you know what we're going to use
a they're looking for evidence so what
the problem is this they've been looking
for evidence for 10 months and they've
only got a reasonable suspicion they're
not given the CCTV evidence because it's
quite clear any reasonable person I know
it's your job to debate so I respect
that you're doing a very good job
because your position you're starting
from a very weak position so you've done
brilliant but the thing is
the the evidence is very clear that it
doesn't amount to that level so when you
look at it there's this issue with CCTV
why they're not putting it there's an
issue with the psych report there's an
issue with the level of evidence there
is there's an issue in terms of the
information that is being leaked to the
Press which is Snippets or the fact that
they're not put in the long form of a
WhatsApp WhatsApp either to the judge or
in in if they're going to leak and leak
it properly well but they're not even
including it when they give it to the
digital so I think that all of that
demonstrates and this is the reason why
when looking at all the information and
even looking at the specific rape
allegations because we've not gotten
into that but this if you look at the
story of the U.S woman you look at the
story of the UK moldovan woman who's
from UK
their stories don't add up there's a
huge problems there's huge issues with
their stories so even the rape
allegations do not stand up and hence
why the judge said you need more
evidence how are they going to find more
evidence
after 10 months whether or not found it
let's be reasonable we know they're not
going to find any more evidence for that
specific allegation in terms of human
trafficking
they've got these they've got these
allegations the judge said go back and
find some more evidence right now they
haven't got the evidence they may find
it and that's not what I'm gonna denying
but that's what they're looking for so
they're in a Race Against Time to find
the evidence
and anybody whose entity is claiming
that look we have got that you know
they're gonna go down but the problem is
as reasonable rational people who
analyze information the evidence isn't
there and I think
um to be honest this whole debate we've
just we've come to an agreement about
everything so
I don't know what else to say yeah I
think that the judge right now feels
like there's compelling enough evidence
that a an investigation
compelling enough evidence that the
investigation is going to turn up
something that's going to lead to
charges you're not allowed to just hold
them there on nothing so he's seen
enough he that's what he's felt that's
why he's denied their repeals repeatedly
um and all we could do is wait and see
what charges actually get brought
against them but until then it's all
just speculation do you agree there's
enough evidence to hold them right now
yes there is enough evidence based on
Reasonable Suspicion to hold them but he
doesn't like other Romanians yeah but
but
you think that the court is violating
international law right because by not
by not because they're not include
they're not including the CCT yeah and a
few of the things yeah and in terms of
the reasonable suspicion
another problem is this that what
they've done is to hold them for 180
days is a very extreme measure you
alluded to it that there is they are a
Flight Risk the issue is this
let's be clear they're not they're not
really a Flight Risk and I'll explain
why uh but you but this is opinion so
you you have a fair argument against me
if you if you want to
so this is not because I've been citing
a lot so the reason why for my argument
is this they've went for a very extreme
measure they could have went for house
arrest they could have had put a tag on
them they wouldn't be able to leave the
country let's be clear if there's some
kind of like James Bond type people
where they can destroy the tag they can
get someone to get break them out they
can get someone to help them leave the
country
that is easily possible even in prison
but in reality these men have clearly
shown that they want to exonerate
themselves in the Romanian system
because they want to respect the country
and respect the laws and they believe
they're innocent
why couldn't they just get in a current
drive away
because they're going to be tagged but
they weren't tagged don't they doesn't
have like 32 cars that they're gonna tag
all of them no no they'll they'll put a
tag on him so they'll be able to monitor
his movement what do you mean by tag on
him there'll be like a a tag they'll put
like a tag on the leg isn't it so that
you can basically would know where he is
at all times oh like a um
yeah yeah so yeah you have that and then
you can have security there as well you
can have many things in place to ensure
that they don't leave and to be honest
look we know the level of wealth they've
got if they wanted they could have got
out Anytime Anyplace this is my opinion
and so and the same argument is for
prison and the same arguments of house
arrest if you believe that they can get
out in both scenarios that argument is
is essentially very similar well if you
feel like there's an international law
violation why would you go back to a
country that you feel like is violating
international law at a stand trial there
I'm sorry I never understood
you're making this argument that they
want to exonerate themselves in the
Romanian system well in that case and I
guess we should just let them do the 180
days or whatever the judge feels like no
no I explained to you that what they've
done is an extreme measure so therefore
what they should be doing is they should
be getting a house arrest with the ankle
monitor to ensure that they don't leave
the house they can have security there
whatever it may be but they're going to
be tracking their movement so the only
way they do it is if they break out they
run away and then they're basically on
the run and for someone like Andrew Tay
this is my opinion who is a global Mega
star who relies on not being on the Run
who relies on his brand he would be he
would basically kill his
what if it was the case that he was
actually guilty of everything charged
would it make sense for him to run well
if he was guilty of everything charged
they could probably break him out of
prison if if he has the level of power
that that we that has been you know the
level of money like an armed militia to
go in well how is he going to break out
is he James Bond how's he going to take
his uncle Monitor and run away and again
like it's probably a lot easier than
getting a crew to break you into prison
it is probably easier but at the same
time it's not it's not easy so the whole
point is both are acceptable measures
the reality is why they're really
holding him is it's not because of
prison it's not because of anchor
because you can't keep him in a home and
that's a fair balance you can have and
keep him at home and ensure that he's on
the run and he'll have to exonerate
himself in the Romanian system I'll be
on the Run for the rest of his life in
reality the court has alluded to it the
reason they don't want him out is
because they don't want him to speak
because if he speaks publicly and says
guess what these allegations are wrong
and he's a very influential speaker they
know that that may make the Romanian
system look bad so hence why they said
we want to ensure that the respect of
the judicial system is remains in the
eyes of the people so that's actually in
my opinion why they are not letting them
out
do you agree with that or disagree no I
don't think so
why do you think it is then well I I
think they have a process that they
follow I think he's probably a Flight
Risk the guy's got a lot of money he's
made a lot of statements about breaking
out of the prison system bribing people
in the prison system or just driving
away or whatever
um you know he talks about all those
passports they probably think he's like
high probability for fight risk the
charges are really serious so but these
are those like but you can't be used in
court
right what can't be used in court didn't
you say earlier that the social media
stuff came yeah yeah you can't convince
them in court but in terms of trying to
figure out if somebody's a flight risk
or not I think the Judge himself has
alluded to the videos of like the him
which again which again isn't that
unacceptable though as well another
point so first of all you know the
bribing point you made you said bribing
people in the prison system he's in the
prison system he couldn't bribe them so
again there's another example where he
was trying to actually saying oh I'm
gonna bribe this man bribe that man but
in reality he's in prison he's not
bribed anymore you don't know if he was
serious or not he might have tried you
have no idea well he might have tried
but still doesn't it
that's an example about the prison
system but we're saying house arrest so
you defeated your defeat was about the
prison system not about the house arrest
the second point was in terms of
possible again another problem I kiss
you they said the the judge the the call
system they took his video like uh from
where he says I've got like so many
passports whatever it is that again for
me is unacceptable why would you take a
video where he's saying I've got so many
passports and use that as a judgment to
say that you know that he's a flight
racing he had multiple passports and
that and you've asked a very important
question and that's the question that
should be asked does he have multiple
passports contact embassies and find out
if he's got them that's what a legal
system is meant to do or have they done
that no because they've said in the core
systems that they've just used the video
on social in the remaining again Romania
they have no idea how many passwords
he's got according to the court
documents right now they're based a
solely on social media have they said
that that they only went on their social
media or was that a leading thing that
they used in a fun further adversation
they said they use social media to make
that decision they did not say anything
about content contact and embassies and
find that information out so yeah that
was the basis okay well I don't know if
they've contacted uh embassies to find
out but I think that there's a lot of
information you can use to determine if
somebody's a Flight Risk that's not
going to be something that's like
completely and totally beholden to like
a probable cause or um uh Beyond or
whatever uh Reasonable Doubt thing like
those these are decisions that judges
make um it's probably not going to be
perfect they're consistent in every case
but I think there are people that have
like a ton of money that are accused of
uh charges that would be like incredibly
um with extreme gravity uh I imagine
that you're probably in most cases going
to detain people like this that's my
guess so my problem is this you said
that they're probably not then probably
not it's not perfect or not consistent
my argument is they should be consistent
so therefore based on consistency see
these guys should be housed on a house
arrest as opposed to being in prison
every criminal justice system in the
world is going to operate on some level
of discretion discretion discretion see
especially when when we're talking about
being consistent when it gets to cases
of this magnitude you might only have a
handful that ever happened and all of
men like in all of humankind right like
this is probably a really unique case I
don't know if anybody's one-to-one
comparison of a guy that did online
um had women and then everything else is
going on I don't even know what
consistency would mean it's probably a
one-of-a-kind case so in terms of what
my point position is um so if you can
answer this my point is this I my view
is this the prison is Extreme an extreme
measure you could still succeed in your
point because part of the Romanian
system is that the 180 days can be
preventative where he has house arrest
do you agree that that would be an
acceptable way of making sure that you
don't go to extremities and basically
show that you're basically you're not
out you know at least there's some kind
of balance in the system so you
um would I trust house arrest
um I mean if it was my call I would
probably arrest a rest if somebody had
that much money that much like
opportunity I think you would probably
just arrest them because getting around
an ankle bracelet or something what does
the rest of us mean as in like detain
them somewhere not like give them an
ankle bracelet and hope they don't flee
the country somehow
so yeah so that's why we do disagree
because we all agree here that if Andrew
but if Andrew wanted to fool an ankle
bracelet and leave the country could he
do that
um hypothetically he could do that
hypothetically he could probably break
out prison but hypothetically speak but
it would be easier though but it would
be easier for Uncle Brisbane but but in
reality in reality he won't do that
because he won't want to be on the Run
for the rest of his life I don't know
well we don't know that though no no we
know that because if you know that
because you're assuming he's innocent
but no no no he's done no he would want
to be on the Run for the rest of his
life because he might go to jail for 30.
no no because the problem is even if
you're guilty or innocent
if you're so if guilt is equal in Ma so
if less if he's found guilty and he's on
the run or it's almost the same because
he loses everything the only difference
is that you're in prison which obviously
much worse but my point is so for him
when he when we look at the evidence it
would be silly to go on the run it would
be ridiculous because you're basically
giving up everything yeah but he doesn't
know we don't know what he's done
neither of us do if he's actually guilty
of this and more
um then it wouldn't it would make sense
for him we don't know as a matter of
fact so you're talking about certainty
philosophical certainty but in reality
what we'd know is based on the evidence
you agree I think we would all agree
here if Andrew Tate if he knew it when
we don't know this we don't know this
okay
hypothetical if he had done all of this
he literally had a text group called The
Lover Boy recruiters and he did all of
it and he raped seven women more than if
he did all of that yeah and now the
Romanian people are breathing down his
neck he'd probably rather moved to
Russia and live there as a as a poor
person then go to jail for you know the
rest of his life I think that's fair if
he definitely did that that would be
evidence doesn't suggest that what the
evidence suggests is that arguments weak
if anybody's in his position based on
the evidence and data that we have in
front of us it would be silly to run so
therefore how's the rest would be more
sure but I'm saying the judge doesn't
know that right no the judge knows the
evidence so the judge knows the
information the judge doesn't know if he
actually come into the crime or not
though if he didn't commit the crime
then it makes sense that he would stay
because he would stay he would fight in
the court system he would win but if he
did and the prosecution was just you
know one inch away from uncovering
something liberal then he's probably
gonna run no but the judge never makes
his decision based on what he thinks
that the person thinks that he would
have done the judge makes his decision
based on the evidence that he has in
front of him and based on the evidence
he has on front of him it's very weak
and So based on that one would surmise
that this person wouldn't go on the run
and therefore they would house arrest
would be an appropriate sure that I mean
that's your opinion on the evidence I
agree I accept that this this one was
opinionated sure
okay
do you think there's any credibility to
Andrew Tate's theory that the elites of
the world want to take him down for
promoting that men better themselves
do you mean for this case or generally
what do you mean do you mean that they
want to take him down for this case or
an agenda yeah like he like before that
he was saying like they're going to put
him in jail like the Elites in the world
are going to put him in jail
um
yeah people always evaluate these
statements as though he's innocent but
he could be guilty right that which is
always the issue right like I might come
out and I might say well listen you know
they're going to come after me guys and
that's because the Matrix is chasing me
and I might say that because I'm just
you know like trying to get views on
YouTube or whatever but maybe I actually
did a crime I'd probably say that too
like guys they're gonna make some crazy
stuff up about me uh you know be be
ready okay and then wow I get arrested
because they found out I murdered some
kind of like see that's the Matrix well
maybe you actually did do that so do you
think they would want to take him down
though I mean I'm sure a lot of people
want to take a lot of people down
including Andrew Tate but the question
is do we see evidence of like a
concentrated effort to actually go after
him in a manner that's unfair I feel
like if we did I feel like when he got
arrested 10 months ago they would have
found a a [__] reason to throw him
in jail or whatever and just kept them
there forever but they didn't seem to do
that so so I'll try and answer that
question so I think it's too late so in
terms of whether the elites want to take
him down I believe is not linked to this
case so basically in terms of at least
want to take him down we've seen that
he's been banned from many Medias
there's a concerted effort to basically
silence him in the UK he's not allowed
to be talked about in schools it goes to
safeguard and it goes to prevent so yeah
there is a significant fear about this
man by the impact So when you say Matrix
what you basically mean is either the
Deep State or the liberal leftist medius
immediate ideology who doesn't want to
give this guy a platform to give men
hope to give men rights in a society
where male suicide is 80 of suicide
adolescent male suicide is 80 of suicide
when when male suffering is huge in this
Society so in that aspect yes but in
terms of this case I don't think so I
believe this case is basically Romania
on its own this is my opinion I believe
it's a Romania on its own and the reason
I think that is
when you look at the way the United
States and United Kingdom do things
other than the patriarch and the
terrorism act generally speaking what
they do is they build the entire case
they make sure the case is strong enough
and then they go after the big guys in
this scenario just looking at what's
happening they're doing a very shorty
job and so when they've done such a
charity job when the evidence is so weak
when it looks like in a normal system
this wouldn't have went forward in the
United Kingdom this wouldn't have been
this would have been dropped in the
United States this would have been
dropped based on that and the terrible
job they've done I do think it's
remaining on its own
can Andrew Tate receive a fair trial in
Romania
yeah I don't see a reason why not
um so again this is just opinionated so
I believe based on what we've seen up
there now
I don't think so because I believe that
the actions that have been taken have
been very extreme in all regards and so
if this continues and is kept for the
full 180 days which I believe is
probably going to happen and then he's
put taken to trial and and then based on
based on that I do think yeah he will
not receive a trial and be convicted but
based on the evidence I don't think he
should be convicted what we have right
now what is your ultimate prediction for
the outcome of the case
uh I think you'll be charged and
convicted at the very least with like
something related to financial crimes
but it's hard to say what the
prosecution will ultimately find
um so I think he will be convicted but I
don't think he should in terms of
financial crimes I did have the same
thoughts as Destiny previously but after
the BBC documentary
um I'm not 100 now and the reason is
because the BBC documentary tried to
relay as though they found a treasure
Trove of evidence based on money
laundering and there was Zero evidence
they flopped really badly and so based
on that if he did this massive
investigation into money laundering and
flopped there may not be evidence now I
accept that the Romanian authorities
will have a lot more powers to look and
regulate into certain look into certain
regulations and look into certain
accounts that they wouldn't so there is
a possibility but I would say based on
the evidence he should not be convicted
but based on it looks like a remaining
agenda I think it will be
has Andrew Tate been a net positive or A
negative for society
I stand at negative I think that most of
the advice that he gives is pretty stock
copy paste advice and I think that the
entire way that he's outside of any
criminal stuff the entire way that he's
built himself up has been basically
through scamming and then partaking in
well most people would agree is like the
most immoral activity that you can do it
running casinos and running Camp
businesses I think that if you're going
to find a role model for young boys or
for young men to look up to it should be
a guy that if he would have stick with
stuck with kickboxing or done some
legitimate type of business I think it'd
be different but the fact that sex
driving aside everything they've been
done is admitted to have been scam after
scam after scam I think is is not a good
role model for people to have
um so I believe is a net positive and
the reason for it is because when you
look at the idea that he's basically
relaying I agree with uh Destiny they're
not like UniQue Ideas he's not someone
who's invented these ideas but what he's
able to do is these important ideas he's
been being able to penetrate mainstream
media in a significant Manner and so due
to that he's impacted the lives of many
many young males and for me males young
males are the Forgotten speech issues of
society they're significantly going
through significant pain and suffering
and they don't have nothing or no way or
no one even cares about them and so for
that reason I believe he's a net
positive in terms of being a role model
look this is the issue I have also which
the Muslim Community always argue as
well they say he's not a role model look
whenever we talk about role models we
never say that somebody is a complete
role model like no one's this perfect
human being that you're gonna aspire to
be like him in a hundred percent of the
way he is what you do is you aspire to
be like that person in one aspect so
webcam business the way they became
famous exploitation of men
actually in terms of when they became
Rich they're not Role Models but in
terms of what they are real Role Models
is Aspire meant to be better aspiring
meant to work hard experiment to not
give up experiment and you know
basically not go into depression 80 of
men have exploded for our committing
suicide
um you know 80 of uh rough speed rough
sleepers who are homeless are all men so
all of these things are imperative right
80 of young men are committing suicide
yeah 80 of the people committing suicide
young men oh I'm sorry thanks for
correcting me okay a lot of people
Precision yeah yeah that would Precision
position is important and um so when you
look at that he is a massive role model
in that aspect
what percent of Andrew Tate's comments
are purely for entertainment and comedic
effect
I don't like saying anything is just for
entertainment or comedic effect the
types of jokes you tell usually
underline some sort of truth that you
believe in like if I if I'm the type of
person that tells a lot of a particular
type of joke I'm probably hinting at
something that's true if you look at any
popular like stand-up comedian generally
they joke about things but they joke
about things that hint at or reveal true
things about life so I don't believe
that there's any comedian or person that
just says things that completely and
totally betray the foundation of things
they believe I think we generally joke
about things we think are pretty true so
so no so I would never ever just say
like I would say zero yeah it's not like
just jokes it's always like hinting at
like an underlying ideology
um so I think there is a possibility
that you could joke and it wouldn't be
based on what you actually believe
because generally speaking you know in a
society there's going to be certain
levels of jokes that are not allowed and
so you're not allowed to say it but
that's in terms of preventing but also
you know certain types of jokes even if
you don't believe them is going to get
you attention and attraction so that's
important but in terms of what you're
saying yeah in terms of his ideas many
of his ideas I many of his ideas when
you look at it you can when you boil it
down to the bare Foundation you can
maybe find some strong academic argument
I believe I can find a lot of academic
Arguments for some of the many of the
points he makes
but the his delivery which is the
comedic fashion is basically there to
which which first of all made him famous
but second of all allowed him to
penetrate society and so someone like me
when I make my academic arguments maybe
people who find it boring and it
wouldn't it wouldn't penetrate but
someone like Andrew Taylor does
penetrate so comedy is an important
factor to her basically ensure that that
happens what is one specific what is one
specific thing that Andrew Tata said
that you disagree with the most
um this is a hard one because it goes
back and forth on this but it feels like
his women his position on women I
generally would disagree with
um the idea that like the husband owns
the wife in such a way that she's almost
like a piece of property that you
cherish your review or
um Revere is something I disagree with
but he's he'll make other statements
where he'll say like well no there's
like a mutual respect there or if the
woman agrees to it and I mean if a woman
consents to that situation it's fine but
I think in general the way that he talks
about women as being kind of like
beneath men or something that needs to
be controlled by men and then any
position that he has on women that
involves these one-sided open
relationships I think are insane
um so I've not cons I've consumed quite
a lot of tech content recently while
I've been looking into the case I'd say
basically when it comes to certain uh
well one of the ideas just an example of
when he said um you know he's talking
about knife crime in the UK which is a a
obviously a problem and then he said his
solution is to basically put them in
prison
um for like for life in Dubai and throw
away the key so if one assumes that he
wasn't saying in comedy because it
didn't seem like it was that's not like
a that's not like a logical system in
terms of like um
um crime punishment and then the
opposite on Destiny is there something
that he says that you agree with
um I generally like messaging that like
you're the only person that can rely on
yourself I think that people need to be
a lot more internally driven I think
that right now we have a really hard
time in society with people uh facing
and overcoming any type of adversity
feels like we feel like in order to make
a good life for somebody you have to
remove every single obstacle in front of
them when we should probably be
preparing or teaching people how to deal
with obstacles and of all of Tate's
messaging I like that part the most and
the part I like the most is which I've
mentioned already is the impact he has
on young men gives men hope you know in
a society where as I said men have
forgotten men's pain is not considered
it's all about female pain and being
female suffering and you've got a
scenario where this guy actually gives
men hope gives men opportunity and I've
had and just from my own perspective and
I'm just a small guy within the sphere
of uh social media but the amount of
people who've told me that he's
basically impacted their lives in a
positive manner taking them out of
depression giving them Focus giving them
a goal
um I think is the more single most
important aspect of what if he is
incarcerated incarcerated which society
will lose and I will I believe that is a
significant loss
if not Andrew Tate then who should young
men look up to
I've thought about this one I had
answers like 20 years ago but I'm 34 now
I don't know um in terms of role models
that young people have I would have said
growing up that people like Mr Rogers
even people like Bob Ross
um I think that these are like generally
good figures to look up to like people
that send messages of like hey you could
be strong but you can also be
compassionate
um you know people that are good like
moral coaches or guides for life I think
are good
um but I don't know I'll get a lot of uh
I don't look at a lot of young male
inspiring figures today because that's
not kind of age out of that
um so I agree with Destiny that the
issue and the reason why is she became
famous and why he's important is because
there is no other male figure you've got
if he's out there's nobody else to
replace him right now and that's the
reason why it's important some people
may argue Jordan Peterson but no I I
don't think so the guy literally is
crying on TV 24 7 he's changing his
position 24 7. he's you know his ethical
framework isn't great so there's many
issues in terms of a Jordan Peterson
that I don't think people should aspire
to be like so therefore if he wasn't
there there's a huge void I don't know
how much life advice he is but like Mr B
seems like a guy that's constantly
trying to give back to people run
Charities give money help pay for
people's medical stuff or whatever so
but what about in terms of uh um so so
of course there's good people for sure
but what I mean is what about in terms
of this aspect or that he
um he impacts on society is there
anybody else who could replace him
uh like I said I don't know if he gives
like moral lessons or coaching like
Andrew Tate does so I'm not sure if he'd
be a one-to-one replacement there
well thank you guys for coming on you
know I put a poll in the chat about who
won this debate it's like literally
right down the middle 50 50. wow
well
with all of Destiny so 51 is what needed
for the Beyond A Reasonable Doubt or
whatever we're not even there
so yeah you're a reasonable suspicion at
the moment but the the point yeah
but I think we do I think I did well
because we've got the all of Destiny's
fans probably bought them for you as
well so but then you probably got hit
fans voting for me so oh man yeah I mean
it's it's a clash of fans is there
anything else you guys wanted to go over
that you felt like you didn't get a
chance to
no no I think we agreed yeah honey well
I'm kind of curious on a macro level how
do you feel about all the statements
Tate has made
about young women about how he would
kind of get people into his business do
you have any feelings about the rule do
you think all of that was just like
bravado and fake or yeah so I I
it seems like it was bravado and fake
and and and that's just me being honest
because when you look at what his
operation was based on the evidence that
we've got now it could be he had that
and then he completely downsized his
business and then never no longer had
that or it was just bravado and it
wasn't there in terms of his ethical
framework like I don't agree with it so
for example from my perspective I've my
ethical framework doesn't agree with any
of this exploitation or this sexual
exploitation like like I said sure and
so when Tristan says he's got like six
girlfriends at the same time and they
all work for him and when Tate says he's
got you know 75 cam girls you think
they're just lying about all that's all
fake I I um 75 is a lot yeah I don't
believe that's a kiss I don't to have 75
girls you would have to have a massive
operation it's just a it's just
propaganda to basically it's similar to
when he says he's a trillionaire you we
know he's not a trillionaire but it's
just to basically propagate your
business propagate it on all those cars
right I'm just trying to think you did
75 girlfriends times let's say you spent
30 minutes with each of them a week so
that's a lot of
Sorry God I'm just thinking that's a lot
yeah I mean what do you what do you
think do you think he had a 75 like
logically based on what we're seeing
based on the information we've got now
um I don't know how many was managing
but based on the videos I've seen based
on ways that I hear them talk about
women and their their strategies and
everything I think that he had a lot of
women that he brought over that thought
they were going to be something special
and ended up working for him and he
ended up like taking most of their money
I do I do think that I I just don't
think that he took most of their money I
think he just followed normal cam
business practices and you can see that
with the regards to the fact that
basically he says 50 you see in the card
documents actually the worst one is he's
only receiving 25 and then others is
much less you say he's only getting 25
it's 25 to him and 25 to his Business
Association do you believe the
statements that he said because if you
believe the ones where he was saying he
didn't pay the women enough do you also
believe because I've seen videos of him
saying that he's made women Millionaires
and he's talked about how rich he's made
a lot of these women yeah but that's
usually in defense of people saying he's
exploiting women he'll say they're like
oh well no I've made the millionaires
but when he's being explicit about that
do you believe that statement No Okay so
that's just weird to me like why
wouldn't you believe that if you believe
the other one because in one he's just
giving a guide on like this is what I do
to take advantage of women around and
then the other one somebody's like well
aren't you explaining so he's like no
I've made the millionaires well like
obviously that's just a defense of of
himself rather than like he's never said
he's never said that ever in any of the
other videos where he's just being very
Frank and he's talking about how he
manages him he's never been like oh yeah
like and these women make so much money
when I've got them with me his
statements are always like I own them I
have access to all their media I'm the
one that chooses how they get paid um
that you know they don't even see their
original paychecks I handle all the
taxes this is what I do that those are
the symptoms so so a question linked to
what you just said do you agree with his
statement that basically these women on
their own would not have made in mid
they wouldn't have made as hardly any
money and it's only re the only reason
they made significant amount of money
and got rich together is because they
joined him and because he has an expert
in the field and he knew how to
propagate the women in in the manner
that he needs to and therefore they
became Rich together do you agree with
us I agree with Oliver except for the
last part they probably wouldn't have
made as much money they wouldn't have
well let me be clear they wouldn't have
generated as much revenue because I
don't believe any of them kept that much
money but they wouldn't have generated
as much revenue without being connected
to him but that's because he was a
master scam artist right him and Tristan
detailed on multiple shows how they
would scam men over and over and over
again to get money to try to meet these
girls or meet them and scam them out of
more money and that's what they would do
the problem is the destiny when you say
master scammer is basically what you're
referring to is the exploitation of men
and the issue no no because what what
you're actually referring to is that
basically a man would get hooked by a
woman and then he'd be sending
considerable amount of money to the
woman with the hopes that maybe he could
have a relationship guess what that's
that's the entire sex industry and I
agree they all exploit man no it's not
even close if you have an only fans girl
and you send her money's on unlock a
video or whatever that's you sending her
money to like a video that's extremely
different than a girl saying like oh I'm
gonna meet you I'm on my way to the
Embassy like just send me a thousand
more so like one of these is very now
you might be of the mind and it sounds
like you are which is fine by the way
that all like sex work is some type of
exploitation which is fine but if you're
gonna say that there's levels of
exploitation right paying a girl money
to unlock a video is way different than
a girl promising she's gonna meet you if
you just send her 1 000 Euro more no but
in terms of the common business you've
got a scenario so you're talking about
scenario when you're unlooking so that's
only fans and that's um Tick Tock isn't
it and with only fans that's actually
what he's been charged for he's not
actually being charged with the cam
business just yeah yeah
so in terms of the um cam business
or the cam businesses they have the same
type of process where I'm not all of
them obviously because I'm not
generalizing but generally speaking from
many of the common people who we've
spoken to they say like yeah the aim of
the game is that where a man likes a
woman and then he can wants to spend
time and then he spends loads and loads
and loads of money now where's the level
or extent of that money we don't know
because only these guys are spoken out
about it in such a crude manner but in
terms of the rest of the business we
don't know the level of where they go to
sure I mean I've heard that before but
the woman generally actually meets the
guy I've spoken to I've been friends
with uh some very big cameras and I've
heard them talk about these details
right you'll get these they call them
whales your favorite term um but you'll
get these whales or Oilers that will
spend a whole bunch of money but they
actually do meet the woman now I'm not
saying there might there probably are
girls out there that are scammers that
lie about every meeting guys I'm sure
that happens no no but he said I would
call them scammers as well but Tristan
and Tristan and Andrew very specifically
spoke about how they masterfully
engineered scams on how to get these
guys hooked how to get them to come back
how to mislead them over and over and
over again they were very explicit about
it not every cam girl does that yeah so
I did see a video where they actually
gave examples when they met as well so
my point is this that you know when you
look at this exploitation
and who does it you may know somebody
who does less level of exploitation or
whatever it may be but generally the aim
of the game is to get a man hope so you
can get money sure but when even when
you said examples of where they met as
well I remember that clip that's where
Tristan was speaking very specifically
in the beginning sometimes the girls
would finally meet but what they
realized is they could make even more
money if they never met do you think it
was the tear clip do you think that the
women were taking advantage of the men
in that situation
if they're receiving a percentage or
maybe a great X percentage that's a
really hard one that the class this is
the problem like you never want to blame
women it's always the guys
I know you're very ideologically driven
on the male version I really couldn't
care less about it that's not what I'm
interested in the example that I was
gonna give and there's a really
difficult question to ask because you
know the um like the um you know the
Indian scammers for like calling you and
like blah blah blah there's always a
question of like should they be held
accountable for what they're doing and I
don't know if you're like a cog in the
wheel of an entire scam business
um versus like the head I don't know
what the level of responsibilities are
that's a personally it's a hard one for
me to say like are the girls themselves
participating in the scamming yeah it
seems like it but like how responsible
are they well what percentage of the cut
are they getting would they be doing it
on their own are they being directed to
do that by Andrew and Tristan like these
are all things are going to factor into
the autonomy that that person has to be
a scammer the problem with your argument
is that basically you're saying they're
a cog but actually in reality when it
comes to scamming that individual person
they're the basically the whole show so
this the individual woman who's
basically exploiting that specific man
so what you're trying to say is guess
what the Andrew te is directing let's
say 10 women and all them 10 women are
exploiting so therefore he has a greater
responsibility because he's partaking in
10 aspects of it but that woman is a
partaking in that aspect so from a macro
level you're right but from a micro
level they both partake in the scam and
they're both equal shareholders in that
like if they're getting paid equally
maybe even in the microwave Factory but
on the Mac what about micro level even
on the microwave I don't think you're
correct because then Andrew and Tristan
talk over and over again about how they
were the ones running the DMs I think I
think Andrew's joke multiple times on
how well the girls in that room and then
I'm in the other room like he's doing
the DMS he said it multiple times that
was one of the reasons why he said he
was making more money with these girls
than they ever could have is because
they'd engineered down to like a fine
perfect formula what they needed to type
the guys in order to get them hooked no
but that's because that was that was
their business model wasn't it but in
reality when you look at it it was
actually specifically the woman who was
in the screen who was basically
um getting the man to be interested in
him so that he could be exploited and
when you look at it as we said if it was
a 50 50 from a micro level they're both
50 responsible if it's a scenario it's
50 25 then what unless it is a scenario
where she's receiving a great account 70
30 then
then she's exploiting much more but like
like here's the reality right if you've
got a guy that's at the head of a scam
and then he's recruiting people and
paying them to be little scammers and I
guess yeah you could say they share some
responsibility depending on how they
were recruited that's a really important
part but they share some of their
responsibility but most of the
responsibility is always going to go to
the head of that thing of course so I'm
just like you're gonna you're gonna
blame like a major dealer over like
random kids dealing on the street of
course so why does it depend on how
they're recruited well because if
somebody says like Hey we're gonna go
and scam a whole bunch of men you want
to sign up and you sign up while at that
point you're kind of like you're part of
the scam you're long for the right
that's kind of your fault but if
somebody says like hey like I really
love you I want you to come to Romania I
want you to be with me we're going to
work together we're going to be a team
of blah blah and then you get things
like listen I need you to work for 12
hours a day we're gonna handle your damn
spray it's it's a lot different the
level of responsibility so the issue is
I love you but we're gonna scam a bunch
of men did I ever say that no no but
that's basically what you said no that's
not what I said
you said basically if they're dating and
then he she does it it's a different
level of responsibility I just don't
understand why yeah of course like once
you're married the relationship changes
significantly right if I found a random
girl on the street and I started to get
her to scam people I was like hey we
should scan people the level of like
autonomy that she has as a person is
going to change versus like my wife
because I probably have a lot more
leverage over my wife because we're
married right or my wife over me right
it's gonna have a lot more leverage
because we're married so yeah that's
going to change the relationship it's
going to change quite a bit there the
radius should probably be different but
the actual impact would not be different
not because we're talking about the
impact of the exploitation and then in
terms of uh the women
um when you look at the women that he's
been who are basically in this case all
of them have been all of them up to now
what we know about have all been in the
sex industry but also again it's not a
level of exploitation where you're
getting some victim or from a poor
country who basically didn't know about
any of this and then you're making them
into it but nearly all of them are you
know in the have been in the sex
industry or have been in a more severe
version of this of the webcam industry
before they ever met him um so Tate's
original claim was that most of the
women now I don't know for the victims
that have come forward they might not
have been on the secretary yeah but
Tate's original claim was that most of
the women that have worked for him
weren't involved in the 6006 report now
whether that was provided and you agree
that doesn't matter in the sense yeah
yeah but um also when you say the impact
equals the exploitation that's not true
the exploitation is going to line the
intent right if I go to a shop to get my
car fixed and they try to repair my
brakes and they legitimately make a
mistake right well I'm gonna go back and
I'll get you know my breaks fixed again
because I messed up but that's a lot
different than somebody intentionally
saying like ah we're gonna fake this one
and charge them anyway right even if the
impact is the same the intent is going
to
this exploitation is a crime that exists
in the mind it's not just in the final
outcome I agree intense is important and
the intent is the same so because if you
get your wife to basically exploit
someone or you get a random person to
explain someone the intent is the same
what your argument is is that the
influence is different but the intent is
the same well do you think any of these
girls that worked with Tate would have
been this scammy with men had they not
worked with hate I thought we all agreed
earlier I believe a lot of girls are
better this scammy with men for free
okay I don't know what question you're
answering would they have been nice
so so in terms of these women yes they
would have been scammy if they had it so
but the only difference is if he's right
which I think we both agree that if
these women were on their own their
operation wouldn't be on the same level
so because the operation would be on the
same level maybe not so but if the
operation was on the same level of
course they would do we have any
evidence that any of these women had
like other men running their DMS and
that they were running long-term scams
on either male clients which are the
women any of them what do you mean
the the claim that I'm making for the
camping business is that the girls were
told by the Tates to intentionally
mislead men about possibly meeting them
one day and that was a way that they
they collected more and more funds yeah
are any of these women
um that have come forward as victims
before the Andrew Tate thing were they
doing those types of behaviors so
basically they were all in the same
business or were so some of them are
strippers some of the webcam webcam
business and so on and so forth so but
in terms of whether they were doing that
there's no evidence that they did it
before or with the tits because none of
that information again so even in the
take case there's nothing about that
okay well if Tates if the tapes are
lying then then obviously I don't agree
the expectation is there but I mean if
they're being truthful I mean that's a
level of exploitation that I don't
believe any of those women would have
engaged in had they not been part of it
what do you mean by lying sorry I just
missed you fine yeah I I if with the
tastes were saying were true the way
they were in their business then I would
say that that level of exploitation is
not something that they would have taken
part in before just stripping is not the
same as lying to men saying you're going
to meet the mixer Etc but it's possible
the tapes were just lying about
everything in which case then right yeah
yeah and I disagree I'll say they would
have if they were at the same level of
Fame I'm curious would your opinion
change if they had only fans accounts
today
so like if the girls in 2023 had only
fans accounts no because I don't
consider only fans exploitation
I don't get you it's not the same thing
as cam work it's very similar wait what
did I say was the exploitative part of
the cam thing
um you said that the men coming out to
try to see them yes okay but you don't
okay VA so yeah is that you don't think
that's exploitative at all wait that was
not expected you don't think only fans
are exploitative I never said it's not
exploitative but if we're gonna measure
something it's gonna be completely
different if somebody's so many only
fans are saying like donate one thousand
dollars and we can meet someday and
she's lying she's never gonna be the guy
and she keeps soliciting donors then I
would say that's the same thing that's
what they were doing yeah I'm standing
Point Destiny but the thing is in terms
of this I know we're going back to the
charges but they're not actually being
charged for webcam they're being charged
for only funds and uh Tick Tock so on
that basis your argument about human
trafficking doesn't it but they might be
doing the same thing on only fans right
that might have been the only fencing
but I've been telling them like send me
this money and then you'll you can meet
us at this area or whatever like they
could have been running that scam on
only fans as well I don't know if they
were or not because I don't know yeah we
haven't got no data evidence for that so
I've only heard him talk about his prior
camping business I don't think they've
talked about the current only fan stuff
unless it applies to the current
business as well so in terms of that we
don't have any information about them
doing that whatsoever no one has claimed
it to be the case
nice
oh okay
um well thank you guys for coming this
was a really fun debate yeah I had fun
yeah super fun you had a lot of fun lots
of fun lots of fun the one last night
was pretty fun too but it was okay I
guess which which one we have people
running away and screaming and running
out the door but yeah and he was
defending me after I wasn't defending me
no yeah he's always defending me I know
I just want to give props to Destiny
because I know you did your hair for
charity so thanks a lot my number
um well do you guys want to shout out on
any social media you have any final
thoughts that you want to say about the
case
yourself a shout out so I can just like
mimic uh I'm youtube.com Destiny and
instagram.com destiny right so my uh
Twitter is at Sheikh Suleiman and my
YouTube channel which I'll be started
posting videos on is the same
my YouTube channel is just pearly thanks
make sure you guys subscribe to it um
and also subscribe to the two clips
channels Pearl daily and um just
probably Clips thank you guys so much
for coming um like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell also go subscribe to
wife school that is the channel where we
you know turn 304s into wives so go
subscribe like the video on your way out
and we will talk to